want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best belief life and get some incredible
motivation from the one and only gary
vaynerchuk if you even for a second
think it's a good idea for apple and
google and facebook
to help you be less addicted you are on
the path of losing
you don't like instagram
delete it
the second we allow ourselves to let the
machines help us help ourselves is the
second you become more vulnerable i
believe that
could you explain that more
sure
like you want apple to limit the amount
of time you're on instagram for you like
you think that's the way that's that's
what you want that mazel tov take it but
like i promise you then there's going to
be the next thing and the next thing and
the next thing
you're either account
social media is exposing us it's not
changing us there is no social media
brother they're empty pipes social media
doesn't make you mean social media
doesn't make you insecure you're
insecure you're mean
we're getting exposed not changed
we're addicted to we're addicted to
human interaction the reason the world
exists in a world where we've had atomic
bombs for 70 years is we like each other
we're not addicted to social media we
are interactive creatures
you're addicted to people
cool you don't want to be on instagram
go read vogue
knock yourself out this is uh this is a
very fun thing for me to watch evolve
um
people don't like being held accountable
so
um
a lot of things the way that these
platforms claim they're addictive
is the way a lot of things are addictive
are we going to ban pretty people
are we going to limit our time to
watching comedy
are we going to limit the time we listen
to music
this is a really this is the demon bless
you this is the demonization of
technology let me give you a really good
piece of advice go read the articles
around the kaleidoscope
i'm being dead serious go google the
early articles around the kaleidoscope
you'll think you're reading about
instagram
history's got all the answers
i failed i could not be in this program
because i failed all my classes but
the one class i was good at was history
and it is the continuous framework of
how i think about a lot of this stuff
literally the articles of the
kaleidoscope are making the same
arguments now
so
if you have fomo
it's because you have levels of
insecurity that are raging which has a
lot more to do with the way you were
parented and where you grew up and the
natural dna you were given
not
snapchat
so how do i think it's going to play out
in its worst
our government gets disproportionately
involved which will be fine
i could care less just so everybody
knows i care about attention not social
media
so if we all stop doing social media i'm
going to figure out where your eyes and
ears are going you're going to go
somewhere
we're not locking ourselves up in a room
so
i don't give a
google and facebook and twitter and
instagram and snapchat and tick tock and
linkedin can disappear off the face of
the earth tomorrow and i'd probably be
the single happiest person because my
most comfortable state is reacting
quickly to where attention goes
um
i just feel bad for any human being that
thinks that's going to help them
because they're going to find something
else to complain about
or to be controlled by this is an
internal framework conversation
not an external technology conversation
i'm really in rarefied air of like
deep obsession with my process and
enjoyment and lack of anxiety from it
and lack of burnout from it i think i
hit my crescendo i think i'm more of an
artist
i don't think people realize that
business women and men are actually
there's a certain version of us that are
artists that genuinely like this
more than anything
like like we like singing like beyonce
is a workaholic
yeah you know like kobe was a workaholic
absolutely over their craft their art
form their expression so for me like
like we demonize it in in
entrepreneurship and corporate life but
we don't in art
we put artists we put oh he's in the
studio all the time wow
you know painting all the time wow
cooking and traveling the world to buy
food wow business oh he's going to burn
out he's going to suicidal why is that
is that just because of the old way of
thinking like getting burnt out in the
corporate world of doing the job you
hate
yeah money money
you know i don't think people like mark
texiera made 213 million playing
baseball but if some entrepreneur makes
30 million they get demonized it's just
culture it's just culture and it's okay
like i don't i don't think that's wrong
right or indifferent it's just the
obvious observation right we demonize
the startup founder or the businesswoman
much much more than the entertainer that
makes way more money what you need to do
if you have this mission accomplished is
worry about your actions not anybody
else's
the biggest problem in our society right
now is everybody worries about
everybody's actions but their own
on every side of the equation
so what i would tell you to do is what
i'm doing for a living which is i have
all i have unbelievable
social wants of kindness for the world
but i'm not going to allow my friends to
tell me how to do that
my friends tell me i need to be a
keyboard warrior on twitter i think
they're full of
and trying to look good on social media
but don't live their truth
so it's about understanding the unique
perspective that you bring and not
letting other people kind of like
play with that
in action meaning
continue to do your podcast
continue to put out content continue to
work wear your t-shirt but not worry
about what anybody else is doing with it
because when you try to boil the ocean
you don't what's been your biggest fear
in all of this or do you feel like
you're pretty fear-proof at this moment
with everything
i'm fear proof because i'm willing to go
to zero yeah you can live on a small
apartment and you know live in your
parents house i really can man yeah
i don't know what else to say like this
has proven it to me even more you know
any point zero zero zero one percent of
me that thought well i've been saying
this for last two years and my fullest
has completely gone away
yeah like i just i don't fear because i
don't value things and money
my biggest fear is my parents getting
sick
like my biggest fear is
like somebody getting sick and dying
nothing else like business i can always
like i'm too capable right like you know
back to back to the thing you brought up
back to why you were an olympian back to
like why you beat me everything that
anything when we were on summon at sea
whatever basketball
you aren't worried
when when it comes to sport
you know
your mind just goes into this is gonna
be a good situation for me yeah and i
feel comfortable yeah and for me that's
business like i know
for a fact that if i became a 100
full-time garage sale thrift store
amazon flipper that i'd make a million
dollars a year i i know that for fact so
what the hell am i and that doesn't take
into account that i am that i built a
brand and sure my brand would take a hit
if i all my businesses went to zero but
the reality is america's funny man like
there's people following and helping o.j
simpson there's you know wolf of wall
street like like this is a country that
gives second third four chances
regardless
and so like i'm already at a place right
now where between brand and capability
and humility
i'm bulletproof the reality is i know
what's going on in the vayner world
obviously i know what's going on
in the broad sense but i spend almost no
time
auditing what other brands are doing and
plus if we're talking from a brand
standpoint
well has to be reflected in business
results there's a ton of people that are
going to win awards today that business
is declining dramatically and i struggle
with that because the point of that
creativity is to drive a business result
in this context or get people to vote or
inspire a movement or cure a disease
like what's the point of output if
you're not getting the end result i've
loved myself the whole time thank god
most don't
uh but i haven't allowed me to get high
on my own supply my humility is my great
offset to my confidence
and i think that manifests and i think
one of the things you were saying
when you were saying it i knew what you
were saying which is you have the luxury
of seeing really behind the scenes truly
and i think what you know is forget
about like giving to a non-profit it's
just the genuine kindness of replying to
somebody's request or doing something
for somebody with no ask no expectation
and nobody knows and you know this
because you run in entrepreneur circles
like i do and you know when you stumble
on somebody who knows me as well they're
gonna bring up something that i did that
was nice and nobody knows about it and
that is only one thing that is called
humility i could be micromanaging in the
philosophy but you know i think if you
speak to anybody who's been a direct
report of mine over the last decade
the biggest argument an issue they have
is i'm not involved enough
i am in the bat phone business what that
means since i'm using a batman reference
and i'm not sure how big batman is in
sweden or now that we're going global on
the podcast
i'm in the business of being uh in
responding to
so
i have no interest in micromanaging
until there's an issue at hand
and so
yes somebody could say that
philosophically but in actual
practitionership or operational the way
this
you know energy that i'm speaking about
manifests in reality is you're only
putting your finger in the hole
that is biggest in your boat at that
moment which means there's a lot of boat
left for those people to run 30 and a
half i'm on this random play i'm just
laying there not feeling tired not
feeling lethargic no cliche thing no
heartburn not i think i'm getting a
heart attack nothing
i'm just laying there and i'm saying you
know
if i treated my health
the way i treated businesses
i'd win
and so
i just started
actually i remember what happened
because i was like that's not doesn't
feel right i was thinking about my 40th
birthday and i was thinking you know at
30 i changed my life
i went from
the executor to i need to go for it if i
don't do from 30 to 40 it's not going to
happen so let me go for it in that
decade
and i was like what do we do at 40.
weirdly i don't feel the same pressure i
did at 30. i think i'm on a better
career path like i don't feel the angst
to like it didn't feel right to triple
down on work
and so i said
health
health is nowhere close to where it
should be i'm not i'm i'm the way i make
fun of people in business you're not
doing anything right that's going to
help you long term i'm not doing
anything right with health when i turn
40
i'm gonna get serious
so then a week later i'm gonna flight
again flights made me think and i'm like
the [ __ ] am i waiting to 44. i could do
a lot of bad in this next 18 months 39
in november this is around may
and in november i'm gonna go for it and
literally the next morning i'm like why
life is broken down into complaining and
not so if you're not complaining
well then i know i have no advice for
you i'm i'm pumped like you did it like
like i have friends who make forty two
thousand dollars a year
um work nine to four kind of with an
hour and a half lunch and 45 minutes of
youtube and 10 minutes of bull
and an hour of complete wasted time in a
meeting so they're kind of working like
six you know hours a week right
but
but but they're pumped right and and and
they text me these are high school
friends and they'll text me like how
happy they are to be the coach of their
kids baseball team
and you know like that's amazing like
that that seems very obvious to me like
that's like that's right like
you know what's super weird i'm actually
weirdly envious
you know like i it sounds cool like in
theory right grass is always greener
right like far less pressure you know
like like all that time with my kids
that would be cool like there's just
like all these things that i can justify
so to me but i have friends who have 100
million dollars in the bank because of
facebook's ipo
who complain who are still hungry who
want to do even more who will complain
to me because they know i work a lot
about no work life balance and they
don't get to spend enough time with
their family and i'm like you have 100
million dollars
like you could stay home like you're in
control like you don't complain about it
you've made that choice don't [ __ ]
me like you want to spend more time with
your family spend more time with your
family my definition of success for me
is to be able to do what i want to do at
all times always and be happy about it
having freedom is everything
has that changed over the years like
no but i don't think i was i didn't
realize what was going on in my youth
you know what i mean yeah
so no i wasn't you know it's hard for
you to really know yourself completely
at this point you'll look back and
realize it was all the same
by articulating it takes time within
yourself and also just takes time of you
actually executing on it
back to like the sub context of what
we're talking about here one of my
biggest problems right now of like
everybody who's trying to make positive
impact is they're doing semantical work
not actual work
right they're jockeying for their
personal reputation by what they wear or
what hashtag they use not necessarily
what they're actually doing and if they
actually ask them once they actually
embrace the fact that they're being
selfish
then they can become selfless if you
actually make pretend nobody else lives
on earth nothing is scary
why is the opinions of others such a
heavy thing for people to overcome i
think it's humanly like this is where i
think like
this is truly my my great gift i'm so
grateful for it i think people got
caught i think they just
get caught that everybody's in this
framework of
other people's opinions like just
it's how we're raised
how do we train ourselves to get out of
it if it's something for 10 20 30 years
50 years we've been living that way the
same way i trained at 38 and a half that
i have no way taking care of my health i
don't like eating habits i don't like
exercising and just pounding pounding
pounding pounding every day everybody
this is why i put out so much content
maybe today's the day that i say it a
different way that makes people realize
their mom and their girlfriend and their
boyfriend and their uncle and definitely
anonymous people on social media and
louis and gary's opinions actually don't
matter
wow the liberation to then actually do
and now you're doing
full throttle because of whether you win
or lose it doesn't matter you can't hear
the cheering this is why i'm trying to
get people out of hearing the cheering
it's my newest thing in the last year or
two i'm like wait a minute right because
everybody says you're so hot on
instagram that when they say you're not
you start doing plastic surgery
right when everybody says like
you're such a great business person you
start keeping up that facade instead of
like it just makes so much sense so to
me the biggest thing is the humility was
such a factor i didn't realize how big
of a deal that was how much that worked
for me is like i don't believe i'm as
great as i know i am
like my logical side knows that i'm up
to something but i just don't
internalize it i won't let it penetrate
my soul i i think i have the ability to
be the biggest deal
but i will never believe it i actually
like losing more than winning i've come
to learn this is something i'm really
trying to reconcile
i actually like losing more than winning
it speaks volumes to why i'm obsessed
with the jets and knicks
and completely have abandoned the
the yankees and the rangers after they
won a championship i
like losing more
micro losing or macro
micro losing but mike but everything is
micro losing besides death or bankruptcy
like being the underdog yep
like i just don't give what you guys
think
and that goes from you all the way up to
my parents
that by recognizing that you guys don't
have the nor my parents has all the
context nobody fully knows you
it's actually through empathy
what age was that like
early
early
like i can't believe how i now
understanding a little bit more back to
like being in your own cocoon
i don't i can't believe the mentality i
brought into high school
like to navigate high school the way i
did which is like completely and utterly
not affected by peer pressure in
hindsight
is wild to me that takes a level of like
self-confidence at such an early age
that i think i just understand so much
more of what i am now really on that
window because that is such a tough spot
and um
that
do you attribute that to
your parents and the work from a young
age or yes
the dna my parents gave me clearly the
way that my mother raised me
um
having to earn my keep
and then just like dna man just like
that voice that we all have like
i just always felt that i was better and
here's where it gets really good but if
the world showed me i wasn't like i
remember going through this is actually
interesting i don't know if i've ever
shared this i remember vividly going
through the ages of like seven to like
16
being stunned
any time i didn't win in something
like shocked
like just could not believe that
rick was better at tennis or john just
beat me in one on one or i wasn't the
fastest in my class or like just shocked
and you know and i've been thinking
about that lately because i just it
sparked me a few months ago i'm like
wait a minute that was weird what was
that because i you know i just kind of
remembered it like shot i remember
actually
what seemed in my mind as a
disappointing thing at the time and now
i look as a great thing i remember
thinking somewhere around 13 14 15 that
i lost my expectation of always winning
in everything every time
and i remember thinking like that wasn't
good but in hindsight i think it was
great because the reality is i got into
this place of complete and other utter
confidence
but being able to not come up with
excuses if it didn't work out
like watching people like lose and then
blame the sun
like literally like what like i
overheard it a couple weeks ago
somewhere uh i was walking like like oh
i'm on vacation i overheard it like this
kid lost to his cousin that look it
seemed to me they didn't look like
brothers uh and he was blaming the sun
and it took everything i had to not like
roll in and be like bro i love you but
like you need to realize like the sun
was there for him too
and i think i think a lot about that
accountability like if you're coming up
with excuses
like
being super confident
filled with excuses when it doesn't work
out is called delusion
so
i feel great because i love process i
think you should invest whether it's you
or the person below you but no further
than that
over a hundred hours of qualitative
consumption of every personal brand
trying to convert on facebook instagram
youtube to just see if there's anything
you
see one of the biggest mistakes ever one
of the things i've never talked about
that i'm starting that literally this
might be the first time i'm talking
about this what's good about two weeks
vacation you get to think like
i don't i don't know if i'm articulating
enough to people how much
research i'm doing
i'm just now i'm doing it with audience
i'm not seeing what you know richard
branson's doing or other i don't do that
i just consume everything my audience is
doing with me
everything
all of it i just i'm just reading all
the comments how do you speed up things
less rules
how do you speed up things less process
how do you speed up things less fear
you know so
you know
this is something that has been my
calling card for 20 years and it is out
of
it is out of complete and utter lack of
fear
complete and utter disdain for process
that is in the mix for the sake of
process obviously some process is needed
and this is ultimately was the first
reason i got into culture besides
having good dna about liking people it
was that i understood that if people
were motivated and excited that great
things would happen versus fearful and
political
the type of leader that will create this
is one
that really focuses on those three
things that i just mentioned for someone
like myself who like wants to go into
entrepreneurship ultimately and like
start a business like i'm interested in
several areas like media emerging tech
all that but i don't really know like
which specific thing i want to do would
you say
to like start at like some company first
and then kind of figure it out from
there or just like kind of go how do you
learn
i i think mostly by doing so done don't
go to a company but i feel like there's
a lot of there's a lot of like
i guess pressure in a sense to like
you know go you can stop this sentence
right there
you know you that you learn that way but
you're gonna do something else based on
somebody else
yeah that makes sense
that's what everyone's doing bro and so
everyone's sitting around and trying to
figure out why everybody
every all these young people are so
upset it's because of all this
because they were over coddled by a
generation of over-cuddling parents
and they don't know how to do their own
[ __ ]
and i think they can do tons of
and believe you can do so much
as long as you tune out
are you in a place where you're
comfortable to do what i lived through
this is i mean i lived it i lived a
world where
for you know now on me
but 26 year old me
was ringing up
my friends from high school at my dad's
liquor store
when they rolled in with their bmw
because they
went to a good school and started
working at goldman sachs and could
afford one or not really but they wanted
to look like they could
and they were buying a case of moet
chandan and i was ringing it up for them
and this is real stories now and
carrying the case to their car and
putting it in their trunk i walked in
feeling fulfilled because i was happy i
made a sale
they were leaving there feeling
unbelievable because gary's
bringing out my case
the problem was that was just when we
were 26.
now that we're 43 it's real real real
different
i just had the internal strength to deal
with that scenario 99 of you aren't when
every entrepreneur who's listening right
now knows one thing that i know
that your business
is your second child is your third child
is your fourth child i have no idea how
many children everyone has
that's the answer because i'm treating
my business like a parent
or your spouse
yeah but but even more like a parent and
i'll tell you why with a spouse or a
partner
that's a a lateral relationship whereas
a child or a business you're in charge
of it
you're grooming it you know it's almost
like your garden right those tomatoes
are going to come out that's you
with
with the macro i can't control mother
nature
just like i can't control the world
but i can maximize my tomatoes this year
if i do good behavior and that's how i
think about my businesses how can you
can you talk about what how you foster a
relationship that engages both
uh employees and customers because i see
this being outside of the company walls
you you this is the style your company
has towards customers as well seeing
them as people
how do you foster that kind of
leadership
by holding people accountable that have
clout
in doing the same
cloud means influence yes
ability to should change things yes
it is imperative that the 50 most senior
people in my company have somewhere
between an 80 to 99
of this in their soul as well
i can't ask them to be 100 of the same
intent that i have
as much as possible and then it is my
job back
to the earlier statement of everything's
your fault when you have control
it's my job to make the tough decision
when somebody no longer is allowed to be
in our company when they don't embody
that mission the biggest challenge i had
to face was about year six seven
six
i was creating entitlement because i was
putting too much on my own shoulders
what do you mean by entitlement
i was making it too easy for everybody
and people got entitled
within the company yep so you were
saying i'll take this on i'll take this
on
in the macro i was creating so much top
line revenue
and everybody was getting raises like
crazy and i was creating such a great
culture that i made us soft
which is wild because you were doing the
sales and the pitching and everything
yourself
i i was i was i was impacting so much
that that 300 400 500 people had it too
easy and we had to do like a 35 person
layoff because i just kind of cut the
fat because i just i and i didn't need
to do it financially i needed to do it
to just culturally get everybody
understand like these people that were
just like oh weren't good at their job
they were nice people but if we keep
carrying this this will die they weren't
great at their job they were not even
close they weren't even close yeah like
like i was it was nice people over
everything and that and that was it if
you weren't nice you were getting fired
but if you were nice
like it was
and it was it was that was tough and it
was tough for me to realize wow on t
with garyvee on keynotes and interviews
on the stage i have great candor and
accountability but in my own shop i
wasn't cancerous enough and i created
entitlement because i love happiness and
la la and
all that and everyone loving you but i
but i went too far with it so that was
tough that was a that was a moment
because i never got to that level with
wine library
because
it was still happening there but it was
a small enough business and a family
business and it was real family cousins
and best friends that it had a different
dynamic so i didn't see it coming so
that was that was interesting measuring
the roi of something
isn't predicated on just doing it it
it's predicated on how good you are at
it
right so like
this is where people get caught when
with this question
the the everything i'm about to say the
complete variable is how good you are at
the thing that includes television
the place where everybody gets caught in
television in instagram and amazon in
everything is they get something to work
in their math
and then they don't realize that they
still have they can still innovate their
creative to do better i think also do
you go into the mindset of knowing like
this could be 100 million or it could be
zero and you're okay if it's zero or do
you stop i go into everything thinking
it's going to be zero really yeah
it really makes it why do you think
notice doesn't make sense now all of a
sudden
i go in with no hope no expectation no
expectation i don't do it for my kicks
and giggles i think i think it's gonna
work yeah
if i'm running it it's gonna work
because that's what i'm good at but
almost everything i don't run
i don't run i don't run purewow 137
hardwood does i don't run vayner sports
aj does i don't run vaynerspeaker zack
nadler does i'm impacting the living
[ __ ] out of them they're influencing
them yeah oh in a real way yeah but you
know push comes to shove i don't make
those decisions and so
um and i support my partners in crime
and so that's kind of how it is i think
the reason my voice is resonating is i'm
not affected by anybody else right now
i'm only affected by the way people are
reacting to me
which allows me to continue to build in
the purity
of human truths without blending and
trying to be like
so you're clearly a very busy guy with
controlling your public image and
you'll appreciate this real quick on
that front just to jump in i'll let you
finish i give zero thoughts to
controlling my public image
zero
i mean they docu
my team's in here i don't even look at
what they're making
the way i control my public image is by
living my truth and letting the chips
fall
it's the most liberating thing of all
time i don't think about it at all i do
think my parents for me and they
appeared to all three kids a little bit
differently but like but they're like he
really they were such workaholics both
my mom my mom was a stay-at-home mom but
like did everything
like you know like like you know and i
think people very much underestimate
stay-at-home moms as workaholics like
she just worked her face off no help
no breaks no breaks we were all
spoiled kids from the fact of laundry
and doing our bed and she cooked
everything and like and then my dad came
home late because and cooked right like
she worked her face off so they could
have created a little more balance we
only took two family vacations so they
taught me work at the kindness
everything everything i am was them
but but i do think the thing that we
have more is balance with you know
leisure and and offsetting 24 7 work but
that makes sense it's generational they
came here with nothing and it was 24 7
work and i have so much to have that in
me but i've had the luxury of my talents
leading to a success that's allowed me
to post you know listen that's how my
first 10 years professionally looked too
but now being able to take a little bit
of time and so maybe a little balance
because i think they regret that and and
so you try to take your parents regrets
and not have the same and so i look at
that that's cool everybody [ __ ] up
marketing because they're gonna always
lean into sales because they need to hit
short-term objectives the end that's
where leadership has to come in and
create
rules for engagement
so i love 80 20. it's why i love army
and navy seals it's why i win i create
businesses like vayner that is my
foundation of 80 and then i taste with
20 around it that's how vaynerx got
built and then even outside the vayner
universe that's how the k-swiss and the
empathy winds and all that this is how
it all works
that's marketing yeah because
everybody's a sales like you're a sales
organization so let's put a little fund
on the side or a little team on the side
and that's marketing and if it goes to
dead zero you've decided at the macro
level that eight hundred thousand
dollars to dead zero is super fine by me
because you know it's not gonna be dead
zero but now you've created autonomy
and lack of confusion and to actually
make that happen i care about people's
emotions
and happiness and and overall livelihood
not what they produce for me
in the short term as an employee of my
company i don't know what else to say i
care more about
i look at our voluntary retention
numbers
ten times more than i look at our profit
margin
and
i'm i'm an hr driven ceo not a cfo
driven co here's why i want to create
clarity for everybody who's listening
cause i'm playing forever
i own my businesses
i'm so for me
i can do things that lead to retention
and a real relationship
because i'm not held accountable to wall
street or a public market or a board
or i'm so money hungry that i want a
yacht and i believe most are what is
amazing about the volume model
is the notion of marketing for the sake
of better marketing
so what happens after you post those 78
is you start getting quant and qual
feedback
and what you do with that feedback is
you make the next decision which is are
you going to write more about that or
has there been such a huge reaction
to people's response
on what 5g actually means to their
day-to-day not just faster and better
battery but how our entire world changes
when you create that speed
of information how that actually makes
autonomous cars real how that actually
allows a doctor in peru to perform a
surgery on somebody in new york how that
actually actually actually does
when you see the response now all of a
sudden you say you know what that little
three sentences we said about did you
know
when 5g is in your life this happens got
such a big response why don't we now
have our
graphic designer make an infographic
real quick
around five things you don't know about
5g and let's post that at 3 37 p.m today
and then when that goes well then you
decide why don't make a quick little
video on our iphone talking to lars in r
d he knows a lot about this [ __ ]
let's go over to him large says it and
then you just post it not with what's
quality with green screen and lighting i
mean i was powdered before i came out
here right now
[Laughter]
that to me is not the variable of
success of this talk
[Laughter]
that was not going to be the variable
that made this go well or not
it was what i was going to say
and lars with an iphone with bad
lighting saying something thoughtful and
then that posted at 704 pm on our
twitter to the small group that cares
matters and so when you get into that
mindset you can see how it works
and it's really just having writers
designers
something we call predators shredders
which are people who can film and post
produce for the channel all in one
person
talent
humans
commitment to being able to pay those
people to do the thing
because you value that more than
the lighting in your booth
at
in spain at a conference the single
thing i'm most proud of sitting at can
is there's not a human here not one that
makes more creative output than i do on
a daily basis and collective period that
is an audacious but factual statement
there's not one person here
that makes more content than i do and
i'm a ceo of a company not a creative
and in that you can imagine in a world
where me and my team are producing 40 to
100 pieces of content a day across all
these platforms there's a
practitionership
that allows me i mean the amount of
mistakes
you know it's fun to have drock here
because he's on the text chain with me
and my team we change our mind
seven times a month
i constantly [ __ ] on my own self once a
week like i emphatically on monday say
it's all about this and literally next
tuesday go if we ever do that again
we're i mean this is real life this is
the truth and you're testing and
learning with yourself
at a scale that is unseen right now and
should be replicated by everyone
which gives me much better insights to
what the consumer's reacting to
and then obviously i'm a human with a
certain kind of flavor so that doesn't
map to dove the same exact way so
there's macro things we see that we
deploy and then we see how it plays out
it's never literal for me to i'm a human
i'm a 43 year old male there's a lot of
things that don't navigate but there's a
lot of the truths that we navigate that
we test and learn there and that we
scale so
it is the ultimate test lab health keeps
me up at night
the health and well-being of the 12
people that i'm closest related to or
loved the most as a friend scares the
[ __ ] out of me
like way more than it scares most people
i think about it all the time
because i don't care about the work
enough
like it's what my passion is but like if
like if a core 12 person in my life is
terminally ill or passes away it will
shut me down
so that keeps me up professionally i'm
not kept up
i'm capable i'm talented business is
tricky because we haven't we don't treat
business the way we treat music artists
and athletes but i think it's much more
similar to that than it is other things
so like once you know you're a good
athlete like you may not win every game
but like lebron's not confused that he's
bad
you know he doesn't think like tomorrow
he's not gonna be able to play he may
not win every game and i genuinely feel
like i'm that like
i'm not gonna miraculously tomorrow
not be what i've been for the last 38
years of my life which is a
disproportionately successful business
human right so i'm good when you're
innovating you're gonna be misunderstood
like when we decided three and a half
years ago to film everything
i knew that that wasn't going to be so
easy to navigate life i mean this is at
least this setting is somewhat normal
how about in your normal day to day when
you're just going to a normal meeting
and you're being filmed like people are
going to cast judgment and i don't want
to come across that way it's just that
the value of content at scale
is the cost of entry for success
in my opinion of this next decade and
yeah that's why we do it there's a lot
of
push towards being a workaholic and hard
work is a learned behavior i see it in
my team there's people that come into my
i've seen it in the thousands of
employees i've had which is the closer
they are to the sun
the harder they work and i'm like aha
and so i definitely feel like i learned
hard work by watching my parents um and
so
it's why i talk so much about hustle
because it's one of the things that
people can actually adjust and turn to i
watch people give advice completely
predicated on natural talent and dna and
i'm like
look like i get it like i can throw a
football every day for nine hours a day
i'm just not physically built to be
competitive at the highest levels
so yeah i do think you know if anybody
watching right now if there's anything
they take away it's like look
like you're gonna only be so pretty
you're only gonna be so smart like you
like there's there's things that are
gonna be natural and there's things that
you can actually control
i do believe and i don't know if i'm
right or wrong i don't but i do believe
that work ethic is a taught behavior
it's something you do have more control
over um
and yeah i think uh you know i think and
you know what really sealed the deal for
me getting healthier
i
was 38 years old and it didn't come
natural to me like it didn't come
natural to me at all i hate the gym i
hate it now
i hate it i don't like it i don't want
to do it um
but i but i knew it was important and
somewhere around midway through being 38
years old i got serious i figured out my
system i made the financial commitment
and
i've won who gets to decide what focus
is
i have a wine company a shoe deal
content vaynermedia [ __ ] wine library
garyvee baseball cards i'm trying to
sell garage sale i'm the least focused
focused you'll ever meet
[Applause]
guys if you're a real entrepreneur you
kind of can't just do one thing
that's how we're [ __ ] up right
like i'm gonna come up with three
business ideas in the next hour
and i'm gonna do that every day and i'll
probably do two of them
in the year because that's what makes us
happy when you look yourself in the
mirror what do you see and what do you
say to yourself
probably the most egotistical things
that i say
i'm probably most egoed out when i'm
talking to myself
which means that i've got a lot of
confidence in ego i real i really
whenever i talk to myself in the mirror
it's always the same thing which is like
you're gonna do it man
you're man you're good like like it's
real good stuff and it's not like false
pumping up i only do it seven times a
year
but like something would have just
happened either adversely or something
great
and i'll look myself and say
we got this i got a funny kevin durant
walked off the field off the court the
other day against the uh warriors
and uh it was a big game day before the
super bowl and they lost the first time
they played in the warriors are having
probably the greatest seasons
and he did something that me and aj took
note of he kind of shook his head and
said okay yeah
and he gave me that like okay you won
but we'll see you and we got a shot i
got this
and it was that's what i do with myself
like if something good or bad is
happening i'll look myself in the mirror
and be and i'll just say
like i know i'm built for this one of
the biggest reasons forget about the
current way people view mark zuckerberg
and facebook
mark zuckerberg's deep understanding of
human psyche was the number one reason
we connected i think i'm an extremely
good marketer because i think this
entire thing that we're at right now
is an internal b2b ecosystem and the
only thing i pay attention to is the end
consumer
i know so little about what's going on
here
this is
this is literally the first three years
i was here i only did this event i
didn't know anything else you guys
remember
harriet just joined us to run comms from
bbdo she's incredible i'm still asking
her on the way here she's like we were
fine finalist what's it called
shortlist she's like we were shortlisted
for a bunch of stuff today i'm like i
don't even know i literally thought it
was finalist like i still adam yesterday
we won a silver thing and i was like
what does that mean like i still am so
deeply unaware of what's happening here
not out of audacity not out of
disrespect i actually love coming here
the vibe i love hanging with you guys i
love this
it's just that everything i think about
is the consumer
it's the only thing that matters payment
money doesn't change you fame and money
takes
the energy out of you
it takes the hunger out of you
when you're not hungry when you're
hungry and nobody's feeding you but then
you get a big 18 burgers and you eat
them all
so i'm trying to i'm always suppressing
the good
that everybody's chasing because it
keeps me hungry
let me give you the most liberating
thing that i could ever tell an artist
or somebody trying to make something
happen
if you're good enough it's gonna happen
i believe in that the most
all the people that are now 53 and they
thought they were good enough they
weren't
it wasn't that they picked the wrong
manager it wasn't that the gatekeeper
stopped them they weren't good enough
especially now my guy
what gatekeeper keep putting it on
soundcloud and spotify
are you kidding me
20 years ago kelly had no shot there
were gatekeepers there's no gatekeepers
instagram youtube spotify and soundcloud
that's the gatekeeper and guess what
even if you run rap caviar you're not
the gatekeeper
you're a mini mini mini gatekeeper
how to show up on rap caviar
that just happened then they pick
but you gotta get that first step love
your fans unconditionally put out music
that's in your soul
will happen yeah man i love that i love
the selfish selfless selfish and
selfless i love pulling from opposite
directions i love giving a [ __ ] what
some nerd in his basement is saying
about me anonymously on your tweet and i
equally love that i don't give a [ __ ]
about what anybody thinks including my
parents and my mom that's the best of
course we all do i'm reading all of it
i'm the greatest i'm a piece of
charlatan and everything in between and
i'm just taking it in and the best part
is i'm unbeatable the people that say
i'm the greatest i'm like [ __ ] you i
suck
the people that like you suck i'm like
i'm the best of all time gonna stick in
your mouth like that's what you have to
do it's the balance
and so we started vaynermedia you know
it's interesting my aspirations were a
couple things i didn't know first of all
the first 45 people that worked for my
agency had zero days of agency
experience
i mean you want to talk about a
show like we want a million dollar scope
from pepsi and on the way out the guy
grabs me and says hey
incredibly provocative you're gonna get
the business this is incredible this is
what we're looking for it's 2009.
then he goes
he goes
one piece of advice i'm like please
because it was so early he goes you need
to hire somebody who knows how to make a
deck
i will never forget that
by the way it took us another three
years before we actually knew how to
make a deck we we are
the fat we are the fastest organically
grown to 100 million dollar revenue
agency in the industry's history
and
we win no rfps
like we're just incapable
because we come in with a philosophy
we're not willing to like you know
everybody sells on an idea and it's just
not something you know we we half
pregnant it we we flirt with it but like
the truth is we have a we have a
philosophy
which is a couple things that we believe
in that i think are unique one we
believe that
volume of creative is the cost of entry
of relevance of the next decade and that
we think this world needs to understand
that quantity does not mean lack of
quality do you feel like you judge
yourself i don't
that's a very very very good observation
and it's what i want for everybody else
we're beating ourselves up
like everybody sucks at something
right like we all have shortcomings and
we all have strengths and for me it's
like why don't we just audit that like
why don't we just look at it that way
and be like all right well i'm good at
this but i'm not good at that like
and then and then and then i only focus
what i'm good at right like i don't
dwell that i can't fix [ __ ] around the
house i call somebody to fix it like i'm
not like i'm not a man i don't give like
you know like like you know like i don't
i don't get it like we all like i also
think it's awesome that i'm so
emotionally stable and i'm the emotional
backbone of everybody is that what a
dude's supposed to do like like these
cliches these stereotypes they're so
silly um you're exactly right man i
don't judge myself i'm fully in love
with myself
but i'm also fully in love with
everybody else too right it's not like
like it goes both ways like i tell
people to buy into me that work for me
it's because i buy into them first
like i don't need anybody to gain trust
with me i've it's there like i believe
that the human
race is so grossly underrated we are
good of course we have some bad there's
seven billion of us
but like when you look at our net score
it's bonkers like do you know how much
damage we could be doing to each other
on a hourly basis and we don't like
we're still here like we won we're the
alpha being and we've figured out how to
stay together this is insane when you
think about it
and yet everybody wants to dwell on like
somebody said something mean you don't
think it's possible to
to grow the entrepreneur i do i think
it's possible to grow anything i think
that i could be a better singer in three
years i think that i could be a better
basketball player do i think i can
become beyonce and lebron even if i
started at six years old no i do not
yeah that's right and so it but but you
have a better chance of being
a notch a master entrepreneur than a
master basketball player i don't know i
don't know is how i answered that i do
think that salesmanship and
organizational understanding and reverse
engineering and pattern recognition
is absolutely a talent and i think grant
it's funny you asked me that i think we
in the world have accepted
music and sports as a pure play talent
and i think entrepreneurship is
something we think everybody has and i
do think everybody can
and by the way
i think it's phenomenal
to go from working at a job and not
being on your own rules to making a
business that makes 89 000 a year but
you get to do it your way yeah in a
world where people need to be more
practical meaning not everybody's gonna
be a millionaire it's just the truth the
data's against you but it is phenomenal
to live a life where you get to make the
rules and you make enough money to live
your life i would only write one thing
down what would that be 51.49 i would
run a 51 i'd run a slash and i ran a 49.
what's that mean
it would mean that i wanted to give
everybody that ever came across me 51 of
the value
and that's how i live my life i so know
what to do with the 49
that i want to give 51.
it's leverage
it's um it's how i think about it it
makes me feel good i love being liked
i louis look you and i run in similar
circles and around a lot of different
you know you know what i'm about to say
is so true and i'm very proud of this
and i am saying this because i want
everybody to hear it do you know how
nice it feels for me to know that
anybody that you talk to when my name
gets brought up that knows me even a
little bit thinks i'm great and only the
people that don't
don't
like whatever i have and hate or
they don't believe the hype or what's he
really about they just don't know me
yeah and anybody that's spent any amount
of time like listen there could be
moments in time but i know that the 137
times i've been brought up in different
cocktail parties or things that that you
you've rarely heard from somebody who's
interacted with me
negative it's always been positive and i
love that yeah and that's 5149 man you
can't be all time if you didn't have
results you can't just say you're one of
the greats i can't say i'm one of the
greatest batman players of all time if i
didn't do it yeah first you have to do
it yeah yeah um but the way he or she
does that is by putting themselves in
the best position to succeed
i met a kid last night business went
from zero to five million dollars in
sales in two minutes all instagram all
the [ __ ] i spewed i saved his life he's
thought i'm the best i'm 27 gary i'm
high energy i'm just like you and by the
time i'm 30 i'm gonna be a billionaire i
stop them i said why are you even doing
that first of all you're probably not
because you're 27 you got 5 million and
i don't see anything that gets you to a
billion in your behavior right now
number two you pulled off the
unbelievable thing and you're
downplaying your success because you're
telling smart people like me you're
gonna hit a billion and thirty and in
three years i'm gonna see you and you're
not gonna hit a billion and you've put
set yourself for a loss and most of all
and this is why i'm telling this story
if you truly are convincing yourself
that you're going to hit a billion by
the time you're 30 and you're at 5
million from zero at 27 and you're not
going to pull it off
all your behavior for the next 36 months
is going to be predicated on short-term
behavior not long-term behavior and the
best way to make real money wealth not
being rich is to do things for the long
term because his life continues at 31. i
think that too many people when somebody
says something they don't like to hear
dismiss it as hate and a troll i read it
and question it and then decide is there
any merit to it and the reason i've been
able to evolve is because i don't just
default if somebody disagrees with me or
makes fun of me that they're wrong i try
to be thoughtful about what are they
doing nine out of ten times it's because
they're in a bad place and they're just
trying to drag me down but occasionally
there's a point there that i kind of
fester in and start subconsciously
adjusting what i'm doing
feedback is important one of my favorite
garyvee
answers was when asked what you would do
if your daughter when she turns 14
goes into her room and is filming all
her videos and nobody likes it and she
comes out and says nobody in this world
loves me and your answer was step your
game up i believe it was the answer
tell us about that the market is the
market man like
like like you know if nobody's watching
your stuff like it's not good enough
like everybody thinks their stuff is so
good like every day gary my instagram's
so on fire it's so awesome why is nobody
like why am i not gaining followers
because it's not awesome
like of course like it's just back to
the scene like you've seen it you all
have friends be like look how cute my
kid is and you're like
you know like like it's what we think we
all think our stuff is the best and like
i get that but yeah that would be my
advice only because that also is
liberating
like p like to me everything's about
breathing right like to me everything is
about like take full ownership for
everything
and then everything gets easy because
then you're in control
and then learn how to love to lose like
for me my game's simple right it's all
my fault
so now i'm not mad at lindsay or drocker
that's it my fault
i'm empowering them so it's actually
true
my fault now
oh we lost this or this didn't deliver
or we
all right
it's an l
like everybody's got losses you know
it's funny uh when ufc started getting
popular i started using it to paint the
picture i'm like look business and
entrepreneurship is much more ufc than
it is boxing in boxing a loss is
devastating
like you know if you ever you know if
you're i'm a big boxing fan like most
big fights like the big big big fights
through here almost it's just
unbelievable amounts of 33-0 versus 35-0
right just like that's like what you do
you don't fight anybody and you get to
that level
everybody's got losses in the ufc
and so
i think that's how that's how
entrepreneurship that's how life is we
all have losses
and so i like losses i love adversity i
like the climb i like the chip on my
shoulder i like when people are like oh
i knew it he's not that good that is
like
like i'm even weirdly scared as i
continue to ascend and i'm getting
popular and
what do you say the marketing leading
like people start putting these words in
front of my name i'm like am i going to
sabotage myself
to like re-correct this like i like
adversity so
yeah all on me
you know i enjoy losses now all of a
sudden like what you become completely
invincible i feel invincible i really
genuinely outside of the health
of myself and 20 people feel 100
invincible as a person there are going
to be times where naturally if right now
i'm in the phase in my health
in working out especially after i really
severely sprained my ankle where
over the last four years
i'm probably at the heaviest i've got
the most fat
that i've had in four years
and
for the last three months i've just not
been in the same zone that i've been for
the last four years i'm dealing with it
by not over judging myself
and so
things ebb and flow like right now
you're in massively good physical shape
i mean you just are i'm impressed i did
biceps today so i'm impressed but i'm
sure you intuitively understand there'll
probably be a chapter where you won't be
as tight on your regimen and what have
you
the way you know i'm very fascinated by
the conversation of work ethic hustle
overworking i'm fascinated by people's
ability to not take on accountability
i i never feel like my points of view
and my thoughts and my hot takes and my
passions and my story are right i've
never believed that in my life
i don't feel right i think i enjoy
sharing them
because i enjoy sharing them i'm a
communicator there's some selfish needs
of communicating i'm sure but like i
share them but
everybody shares them this thought
that
you know
i think one of the biggest things we
need to get more thoughtful about is
this question which is
the answer to the question is by
conversating with yourself and trying to
develop self-awareness and not look for
outside validation when people email me
and say garyvee i've been hustling 15
hours a day i'm like you getting enough
rest you good are you like are you
pumped
like with intention my intention is to
be happy and so i'm not going to
apologize for enjoying my work talk
about like society wrapped up in vanity
like of social if you are a high school
guy who's a nerd but you get a blue
check from instagram your life changed
change you get any girl you want
the amount of people that send me things
like i will rip my arm off if you can
help me get verified and it's like
literally things like i will sell you my
children
if you get me verified on like i give
you my home that's crazy and live in a
cardboard box and i'm just like this is
the saddest [ __ ] ever
and and a lot of my content in the last
six months has been like please do not
get wrapped up in likes
and you know
your rank in the podcast list or checks
like that is such a death game you will
lose that game you will start pandering
to those results versus actual results
by creating a great product consistently
new york times bestseller list yeah i
don't pander to that i don't want to
hire the companies that get me on the
list i want to sell more books that's
the kpi impact more people that's even
the bigger kpi
but look i mean
the world has always traded on i mean
you know do you know how i'm sad at this
point i am when i'm on these 30 on well
i'm not 30 excuse me like top 40
influencers or 50 under 50 now which is
the only thing i can do
so you know i think that you know i hate
it because my feed gets filled up with
like congratulations or the other people
that are on it trying to get me into a
conversation
not because i kudos to them because i
was the most pumped too when i was like
10 most important people in the wine
business under 40. like amazing i get it
but it's
as you get older you realize how those
awards or those like just completely
arbitrary things of like an editor liked
one of your podcasts and decided
and we all get excited yeah like six
best podcasts to listen in 2018 you want
to be a part of that you want awareness
here's what i would say we've over
corrected a lot of people into caring
about that more than the actual results
and so we care more about the facade
then we ca we care more about like look
how nice my room like this we're in a
beautiful room right now right you've
really done a nice job
i like how you put like the more
important people on their own
like wall over here well they were just
bigger photos
you made them bigger i know you but but
here's what's interesting to me
what's interesting is if the concrete
and steel under this building
well this whole thing falls so it didn't
matter that you put something like how
pretty it is exactly and i think right
now too many entrepreneurs and
personalities and people 98 of the
people that are listening to this
podcast right now are caring about the
decorations and the curtains and the
painting in the room not the steel and
the concrete holding up the room and i
think that that's an important
conversation to be had i think a lot of
what makes me happy and worked for me
has been the steel in the concrete
let's come out of this leaning into
humility and gratitude and that will be
the springboard to everything you want
if you can like just be grateful yes you
lost your job or your business not as
good but your grandfather didn't die
from corona
you know just be grateful like grateful
for the time you're spending with family
now grateful for the innovation time the
thinking time i'm sleeping more than
ever i put on a couple pounds so i got
to be a little bit more careful but i'm
gaining real muscle i'm starting to
really do it strong man
soon uh but i'm not gonna dodge you on
that you're too good but um
gratitude and humility other people i'm
watching here are 24 and are regretting
already i'm like okay
i need to help them think about this
because that's a bad framework because
if you regret
if you're that insecure if you're that
if that's your perspective
then you have no right answer
because if you go and travel and you're
34 you're whatever you are financially
or professionally at 34 you're like
i should have worked more [ __ ] argentina
if if you know or if you do the other
thing and you work your face off you're
like
i ended up just like gary all my friends
had fun and yeah i got a million bucks
at the bank but i'm sad because i wish i
went to the
beach more often so so either you're in
that framework or you're not which is
which is a great way to put a bow on
everything i've been telling you
you want to blame other people the
government google
knock yourself out you will go to the
grave blaming somebody for something so
i think people have now aspired to be an
entrepreneur when they're not and those
are the people that are going through
depression are suicidal are unhappy
because they're in a game that doesn't
match them
so when i say that it leads i'm playing
chess
it's never a one size fits all i want to
see what the person says next
i'm looking for the tell
got it brother yeah i'm like i'm like
you know well listen don't over stress
you got patience your 20s is a good high
risk high reward time if it's in you
like if you said that to me if gary said
to gary yo go to europe go this i'd be
like
right me too me too well that's what i'm
looking for okay because when the kid
says yeah you're right i'm like uh-huh
and i couldn't breathe
and i couldn't breathe yeah
i had to i had to do it every second i
couldn't breathe
this is when you're a natural purebred
you're in beyonce lebron
pablo picasso category you're an artist
you're an artist there was no choice i'm
not doing this for the
flex or the ram or the money or the
house or the jet or the i don't want a
single thing i don't want to be part of
any exclusive club i don't need an
island i don't need a hou i need the
game yeah
sales and marketing is mixed
and that means you're actually doing
sales
and if marketing is put into a place
where it's all upside
because marketing is gray
it is intuitive right
so if if the rule is 500 000 i'm making
it up and like there's no like at the
end of the day it's like if you were the
head of it for me i'd be like it's 500
000 and my team will tell you this
james will definitely tell you this it's
like i don't give a [ __ ] we'll talk at
the end of the year explain yourself
but i have no judgment i'm not booing or
cheering along the game just tell me
when it's triple zero and explain to me
why we lost 112 to 88 or why we won 112
to 88 and you just hold that person
accountable that's how marketing needs
to work because that's marketing
you have to be able to do something
ridiculous like buy fifty thousand
dollars worth of bananas and send them
to dentists just because it's so
ludicrous that they're like what the
[ __ ]
you see where i'm going now like like as
as silly as what i just said to you you
you would be shocked how smart what i
just said actually is based on how silly
it sounds
the world is busy
the way you break through is by breaking
patterns if you're a dentist and you get
a banana sent to you in the mail and you
wrote a note on it in pen that's just
weird
weird enough to give you awareness i do
not like negativity and so in my early
years since i started running companies
right from the beginning
my historic vulnerability that i
continue to work on and is far great in
a better place than it used to be
is in my
unbelievable disdain for confrontation
and negativity
i wasn't uh
cancerous enough
and would surprise people when i would
fire them
and also created a level of entitlement
which usually led to the firing because
they weren't getting negative feedback
they were just getting positive
reinforcement
and suddenly something happened and they
became delusional and unfortunately it
wasn't that suddenly something happened
for the last three years they've always
been bad at these three things i just
don't focus on negatives i focus on
positives they don't hear anything about
it and then they get called into the
meeting probably thinking they're about
to get a raise because four weeks ago i
gave them a high five about something
they do do well
and then i'm like hey jan hey rick
you know we're gonna have to talk about
you not being here and they would be
flabbergasted
and i
would defend my actions to myself in my
20s and early 30s on their delusional
how did they not know couldn't they tell
but but a lot of people don't deploy the
self-awareness that i was gifted with
it's not you know uh
and
and more importantly employees always
have other side like everybody there's
always two sides to a story so over the
last three or four years
and i'll tell you that my brother aj who
was 22 years old when he became my
partner at vayner media 10 years ago
he
is far
you know
he's a good balance my dad is over
critical and only focused on the
negative so i think i naturally was over
positive but then being in the same
company with him and a father-son
i almost had to be a hundred percent
positive to offset a hundred percent
negative and that's the truth you need
to figure out who you're most upset
about losing in front of
what if it's literally everybody here
that's great then
you need to start really thinking about
creating behavior to make yourself lose
more
you basically are in the same place that
a slow maturing
11 year old is
who hasn't started swimming yet
the only answer to your question is to
jump in the pool
i if you were like my younger sister i
would tell you that everything you
should do for the next five years
are things that you're likely going to
lose at until it becomes so numb
that it changes your relationship with
losing
losing hating to lose in the way that
you're describing it is completely
predicated on not being able to deal
with other people's judgment
and that is a tough spot to be in
you know
you gotta reconcile that with i'm
probably the most competitive person
i've ever met
or just in the mix with the other people
so i'm trying to win
i don't
want to lose
but i respect the game
enough to accept it
and i weirdly get good tingles from it
because it excites me to try again if
you actually knew that you would never
find out what the alternative was
it would get real good
you know how easy it is for me to make
decisions
super easy do you know why i wouldn't
know what the alternative was
you don't understand it
because you it's not practical
i don't have time to dwell on the fact
that i passed on uber twice which was my
best friend of any investment that i
made every person i invested in was not
as close to me as travis was and for
some miraculous
cosmic reason i passed on uber twice
which made up means that my 50 000
investment which would have been worth
700 million dollars today didn't happen
and when i tell you i don't think about
it at all here's why i'm smart and
thoughtful of
knowing how life works had i made that
investment everything would be different
maybe i'd be going to
india to give a keynote about that
investment because i would have much
bigger profile much different resources
and maybe in that private flight
maybe that flight would have gone down
and i would be
so dead just don't overthink the other
possibilities because i always find that
that's hard it's the biggest weakness
everyone has
they're trying to spend time
on something that doesn't exist
there is no time machine
sorry you picked the wrong school
or sorority or girlfriend
or major
sorry
what are we going to do what are we
going to build a time machine here
your practical optimism it sure is
because it's both optimistic and
way more practical when you're gonna
start talking
what are you waiting for
if you are not communicating you don't
exist i believe that
if you're not communicating you do not
exist more importantly communicate about
what you love
what what what scares me about the long
tail of the internet is i know there's
somebody sitting in here who's watched
every episode of friends
okay
deeply loves friends
can't get enough in their own mind of
debating rachel and ross
loved the show
watch it every night to go to sleep too
and i know they make 49 62 88 100 3 000
a year doing something they don't like
and i know that if they started a
podcast about friends every day when
they went home instead of consuming
content to escape the fact that they
don't like their job
if they created content around the thing
they love that after 24 36 48 months
that
along could have came netflix and been a
sponsor of that podcast
that would allow them to actually leave
that job they hate and now be a
full-time friends podcaster
you don't believe that i understand that
that seems like a far-fetched story to
you the problem is you don't live my
life because i wrote a book in 2009
called crush it that laid this out and i
get to live the best life now where i
get three to six emails a day of people
that tell me this exact story
whether it's about pickles
people like pickles
i do i eat pickles like crazy
star trek
esports don't even get me started
because i used to push it a lot and
people have gone completely and made
real careers now just stuff
i just
i just
really really really hope you hear me
today i'm completely driven by gratitude
do you know how grateful i am
like
do you know
what did i do
my parents had sex at this one moment
and created me
like like
i'm being serious i'm just grateful like
i have such a good thing going people
like it i like it it's so good but like
what did i do
like you know how lucky i was that i was
an immigrant do you know how much i'm
driven by a chip on my shoulder do you
know how lucky i got that i was four
foot 11 when i went to freshman year of
high school like all these things went
in my favor
i don't know man i'm driven by gratitude
that every morning i wake up and i'm
just grateful grateful grateful grateful
i'm 42 years old almost
and unfortunate thank you and
unfortunately my grandparents three of
my four grandparents died before i got
to know them so so not only was i born
in a communist country where capitalism
and entrepreneurship is [ __ ] on i went
to the place where it's most on a
pedestal i got the greatest mom in the
world my dad taught me work ethic
and my word which made me not an artist
saved my ass right but then on top of
everything else i've had very little
death or pain around me and i'm 42 years
old it's unfortunate why that's the case
given the circumstances before but it's
still my reality right and then i have a
communication style that for some reason
who knew don't forget i was 33 years old
before i even made a video like i didn't
even you but i never thought this could
be real like i didn't even cross my mind
i was a businessman
like
watching 20 year olds that are hungry
and thinking about their lives right i'm
excited because i'm like bro you don't
have any clue where this might go
because you know in at 31 years old i'm
like maybe i'll make a video on this
youtube thing like you have no idea
where it's going so i'm completely
driven by gratitude i'm so thankful i'm
so grateful i think one of the reasons
i'm successful and one of the things i
try to push a lot of people to think
about is can you love your process you
know if you're in this and
entrepreneurship is cool now
if you're in this
too cool that's exactly right if you're
in this
to flex on instagram you're gonna lose
yeah and uh
and i was doing it when it was in the
80s and 90s in america
entrepreneurship wasn't a thing that was
actually in this country people thought
it was something bad
in america too if you're a bad dude if
you're an entrepreneur you're actually a
loser living off of mommy and daddy yeah
it was it was you're exactly right you
and i know this a lot of the kids don't
know now
it's like being a rapper or an athlete
it's incredible for me to watch what's
transformed over 30 years
but i was willing to do it because it's
all i could do i i listened to athletes
actors and actresses
singers
artists and in their documentaries
inevitably they're like well i just
couldn't do anything else and as an
entrepreneur that's how i think what do
you have to do to be successful
i think people like us
um
don't understand how i think
in history people look back at what i
figured out as a really important moment
which is it is remarkable
that i don't spend any time
being gary vee i figured out my model
which was following me you're not gonna
be able to do that
if you take 15 to 20 minutes and whether
we help with that infrastructure you get
an intern million different things but
if let me tell you how easy it could be
if you text i'm gonna just use them sal
and be like this week i want to talk
about cryptocurrency
if sal shows up downstairs at the bar of
your building or at the starbucks and
that 15 minutes is sal asking you four
questions
and you answer them and then that is a
linkedin post
the next day in first person
sal writing it
that is that is what i've done i run a
900 person company i'm not i don't have
time to do like what i'm doing is i'm
filming this right now this meta moment
might be how a busy executive said i
want it how a busy executive needs just
15 minutes to be in the content game
this right here is how i figured it out
right originally it was the askgaryvee
show where i did have to sit down for an
hour and interview hannah and her six
year you know at vaynermedia right
now i've gone much further down to
dailyvee where i'm just being filmed
because i don't even have that hour to
do that youtube show then i did that for
three years and all of a sudden i'm like
that content's getting stale and weirdly
in the last month i'm back to doing a
little bit of askgaryvee i'm fighting
for that hour so but the key is
how do you not destruct yourself
but you need to have something that's a
pillar
that got you here
this is when all the new characters come
into your life and start telling you how
to do it different i'm getting more
ridiculous in my truth right than ever
the bigger it's getting
like
if all these people know i love when
people got voices like that are not
living it
and they're gonna give you the
commodity advice
you know like you've got to start doing
yoga you got to start eating granola
like do do the [ __ ] that got you here
well the stuff that got me here roughly
speaking would be like fast food uh hard
drugs uh i promise you a set of alarming
rate wrong okay not those things no no
those things are great
great no
wrong the things that got you here is
you were willing to do that in the face
of people telling you not to do that
and so maybe you don't need to eat a fat
burger anymore and do whatever the [ __ ]
you want but you need to triple down on
your intuition and do that's how you got
here
did everybody think it was a great idea
to be a bmx website dude no that seemed
like a very strange idea to many people
at the time so like listen my man
honestly this is the time you have to
quadruple down on what got you here the
thesis not the direct action but you
don't see people run themselves into the
ground you've never been concerned about
that at least for yourself people run
themselves in the ground when they start
wavering from what they are and they
start doing behaviors that don't come
natural to them and then they break and
the ones that do don't
henry rollins figured that out
he would have run himself in the ground
if he wanted to be mick jagger right and
mick jagger would have run himself in
the ground if he wanted to be somebody
else a politician when you do the [ __ ]
that you don't want to do because you
think it's the right thing to do because
you graduated to the next spot you lose
you know listen at the end of the day
vanity metrics
whether that's followers on instagram
whether that's the jewelry or car you
drive no matter what it is at the end of
the day underneath all of that there
needs to be something tangible and real
and if you're not asking for business
and more importantly if you're not
selling something you believe in you're
finished
the single reason i think i'm a great
salesman as somebody who hates to ask
for a sale
is because i deeply believe in what i'm
selling whether it's the wine i produce
whether it's a sneaker collaboration i
have with k-swiss whether it's vayner i
i sit in this you know what it feels
like to sit in this room and know
think know that vaynermedia is the best
marketing firm in the world
it's empowering you you sell with
conviction
and i just watch way too many people
uh either
be deeply insecure about what they're
selling because deep down they know they
have no idea what the [ __ ] they're
selling they don't know what they said
that's right or
they're just broken they just so care
about money they know exactly what
they're selling they just know they're
selling
and they're
preying on people's fears and i want to
kill those
you know i started the agency with 45
people that didn't work in the industry
i knew nothing about the industry i read
nothing about the industry so i started
vaynermedia i built a creative shop that
i put media in the name
i
had both media and creative under one
roof and had no idea that it was unique
so we were doing all these unusual
things
what it led to
is
a very large agency that has not played
by the industry rules but has driven
business results for its clients so now
we do have
900 people globally we do have the us la
and new york offices and
london and opening up singapore and
very frankly feel very confident we're
about to get a big scope for the world
cup in qatar and that means middle east
and looking at
you know
south america so i i think it's going to
be interesting to see what happens i
think
because of some of the awards we're
winning this week just i'm feeling from
the creative class here a little bit of
more of a
okay you can be in the club and i'm
laughing i'm like i don't want to be in
the club
i don't mind to be in the club
but there's only one club i want to be
in which is
wouldn't you want to be a creative that
in real life when you hang out with your
friends people know what you're talking
about
like how many more times do people here
want to spend 20 years of their life
making tvc that when they talk about it
and they're like you know the ibm spot
and their friends and relatives like i
have no idea what you're talking about
and if they do it's because they tried
really hard to find it
right um
i think that people want to i think if
you're creative i think you want it to
be seen
i just don't know what else to say and i
think you know what mike and adam will
tell you if you decide to yeah with them
after this is after having careers in
fancy places doing fancy stuff it's fun
to make
it you know think about all the ideas
that you guys have had that will never
see the day of life
like you guys are all 12 years away six
years away
four years away from being the final
decision maker to actually see something
made right now you're politicking
and and strategizing on how to convince
the two people above you to actually
make the thing you believe it
you're not in the creative industry
you're in the internal politicking
industry
that's why volume will set this industry
free
we have interns from day one
in ad school
being able to see their thoughts in
market from the biggest brands in the
world
literally in terms of we have literally
interns already in our company that have
had more pieces of content seen by
humans than some of the people here
that's real
that's going to play out i hope for all
of you
i want you to be in a place where you
get to be creative for real instead of
working at a bank
and uh
fighting for
a half pregnant version of your idea to
see the world
and that's why so many of you have to do
things on the side
because you can't scratch your itch
there's a really dirty secret in the
strategy world of like being a mckinsey
where if you really get them drunk they
admit that the actions lead to the
strategy not the other way around
that's my answer to you
how i make decisions
and then i try to look at my calendar
the week ahead and see if any decisions
i made four weeks earlier that made me
think this was a good use of time
am i able to move something cut
something down i'm extremely thoughtful
about cutting times and meetings
so one of the things i think that really
makes me successful is understanding a
seven minute meeting is real
and not just making it a 30-minute
meeting
um
but the real reason is because i don't
overthink it i'm operating my business
i'm in it
how do i decide between going to dinner
with kevin hart
because i can
and i want to build top of the funnel
brand
or do i go take a mid-level client that
i'm trying to build a relationship with
it's you know you ask every normal
person it seems like those aren't super
close but i can touch the pulse and be
like i'm going like four more times in
the next three months
you know the biggest mistakes i make are
the ones of missed opportunities of the
things by being crippled by opportunity
when you actually level that all up my
friend it really is liberating
you will never even come close to making
the right decision
i mean it
you just don't know what the alternative
would be people think that there's a
right answer
you as an operator of your business
make the right call that feels right at
that moment
and just move
and people spend all this time and money
on trying to think that there's a proper
answer i
play on the extremes i i spend as much
time as possible on the things that are
showing me the most offense
right however you're doing your customer
acquisition to get to a hundo on a
product like that like whether it's
facebook whether it's brand whether it's
and then i spend the amount of time on
my biggest vulnerability
you know putting my finger in the holes
to make sure the boat doesn't sink
and building a bigger boat and nothing
in the middle
and knowing that i'm making that
judgment at all times and the second i
get new data a week later i might have
to completely change what i thought was
right the week before
it's also why i spent a ton of time with
my employees
the reason i'm an hr driven ceo is if
you really understand this
both your biggest growth and your
biggest vulnerabilities are actually
your own team
so i think it's a lack of
it starts with the ability not to over
judge yourself
because that is the liberator of the
model i just broke down for you you guys
know grey goose
the guy who invented that as an
entrepreneur invented it at 78.
sidney frank
78 years old
you know
life is like sports like
one of the great moments of my life with
aj is the monday night miracle at the
meadowlands with the jets dolphins that
was 30 to seven in the fourth quarter
and they won they came all the way back
my cousin left went home to queens went
to sleep i called him when they tied it
at 30
and said can you believe that he's
already sleeping he left that game and
was already sleeping in queens i was
like what are you talking about hung up
and then the dolphins scored i made it
37 30 and we blamed bobby for waking up
but like that's life like you could do
everything wrong
have every dream you've ever had
get
blame it on other people the girl
that injury
coach it up blame everybody have
everything go wrong be 57 years old
and still have 40 years to make it right
it's crazy honestly like if there was
some crazy new drug that i could like
inject in you that gave you perspective
of time
you guys too
that's the drug i would give you
straight up
it makes you optimistic
people are sitting here dwelling already
dwelling
shouldn't come to rutgers knew it
of course there's people thinking that
like that's just real life
dwelling already haven't even
started
man that's what i want to change the
only thing that you can do wrong
is not being yourself
i see a lot of people scared to actually
be themselves because they're scared
who's watching and like i hate looking
at all your linkedin accounts you've got
like a suit and tie looking all
professional like you think something
bad is gonna happen if you're you're
normal i look like a mess
up here
i'm wearing a tierra whack
sweatshirt like the results always win
and i think a lot of people hold back
their natural self
the market doesn't care in the end
somebody may judge you
but the market doesn't care everybody's
got so much pressure to like have it
figured out when they come out of school
it's time to be real in real life and
all that
stupid 22 to 30 should be experimenting
travel if you like and people like well
i don't have money i'm like you can
still travel you can get a
plane ticket you can take a bus like
dude
so i think you're not going to find what
you like it's like food i'm always
fascinated by oysters
the amount of people that think they
hate oysters
even though they've never had one
i see so many people living life that
way you don't know your passion because
you haven't done billy i learned from so
much doing that's why my data is so
clean it's why i'm an innovator that's
why i'm fast it's why a lot of good
things happen for me because i realize
just the doing
is actually more efficient than the
thinking about it
somebody said something really smart
funny to me once
and it was like the dig of this version
and it's a really funny conversation
he was talking about vaynermedia at the
time this was maybe five or six years
ago he said you know gary i gotta tell
you i love your company but i gotta
take a little bit of a knock on you he
was trying to set it up i'm like okay
what is it
he goes where i'm where i think you need
to be more thoughtful gary is
i have a feeling though that you might
run through that glass panel and sit
with us when you could have just opened
the door
and i said yeah but which one was cooler
the internet's here
it's a complete land grab
there's unlimited opportunity
nobody cares where you started
nobody's stopping you
there's nobody that's got to take your
resume there's no grades that matter
none of it what matters is are you
willing to hustle
and how bad do you want it
and are you willing to live a life where
you're not letting other people judge
you so then you're not pandering to it
what is one piece of feedback you're
most curious the truth yeah but about
what whatever the hell is in front of
them
running an operation is not a education
or philosophical exercise
what do i want i want to know exactly
what is an issue operationally right
this second to you from your perspective
and you running your world
and how can i help
on your leadership what are you most
curious about the reverse of that coin
what can i do to put you in the best
position to succeed are you looking to
talk to me more often are you talking to
me less do you need five do you need
some leeway with your financial p l do
you need me to rah-rah the troops do you
want me to go talk to the most senior
client because the client that you work
with which is the second most senior
client is giving you a very difficult
time i am in the ambulance fire fighting
emergency doctor
bat phone business i am only built
to act
in helping
for you to succeed within this framework
the things we said no to that were
actually the trigger to a hotter to a
streak to heater that we said i i hope
that heaven is where it shows you
what life would have been based on
choices i loved that i
didn't go to some
night where at night would have been
these two people that would have made
this deal with me like i love knowing
that like momentum is based on choice
that i've missed momentum many times in
my life and that i've gotten momentum
many times in my life and i love that
part of the game actually which is like
decisions actually matter
and sometimes when you have the humility
to go to a thing that doesn't seem right
you get you get something that triggers
a domino and sometimes when you go to
something you're like i mean i remember
sitting down there's one meeting i
remember very vividly with howard
schultz i had a meeting with howard
schultz to kind of just i was getting
hot getting in this you know and like i
got connected i remember sitting four
minutes before i'm like i'm about to
walk in here
and i'm about to blow this dude's face
off and it's going to be a foundational
thing i walked in we had a 15-minute
meeting 20-minute meeting and nothing's
happened
and i didn't feel like i had an off day
i felt like i gave it but it didn't
click whereas when i went to go see
jimmy iveen uh for this meeting i'm like
i'm gonna blow his face off within three
minutes he's like you're next simon cal
and he casted me in the apple show
playing in the apps with will i am
gwyneth paltrow and jessica and if that
show actually got seen unfortunately it
was before all the ott stuff and the way
tv like that would have been white and
that would have been one of the moments
so you know the reality is is that wow
you know like i love that kind of [ __ ]
and then i love i'm trying to think of
like something good where like who do i
meet randomly like i'm trying to think
of a real logical thing well you know i
took a meeting with the jets president
at a bagel store because he wanted to
sell me a sky box i told him about where
the world was going we became great
friends that's matt higgins who's on
shark tank who's steve ross's right hand
there that led to him leaving the jets
years later going to the steve austin
dolphins that became the
gentleman who bought a piece of my
company and like that beca that bagel
meeting became monster meeting for me
and i didn't know who matt higgins was
going into it so
i i
i love chance i love momentum and i love
what starts momentum that's where i just
took this yeah more than to remind
everybody right now say yes
you know one thing that i hate about
people that haven't achieved anything
and people that have achieved everything
they overvalue their time and it's a
tricky one
if you haven't gotten there yet
what's your people like gary i'm not
doing that pro bono work i should be
compensated i'm like bro your word your
work's worth nothing
like there's 700 000 video makers that i
can that i can tweet right now like
sorry like like when your work's not
worth anything like when no humility and
then
and then on the and then again no
humility when people get fancy they
don't take i take so many small meetings
i do so many things like tea with gary
vee in the morning during this covert
crisis to like just
help and once every eight thousand times
it helps me where you end up
in your you know your career
is going to be predicated on many things
and talent is one of them
your ambition is another circumstance
you know all of us if we have a tragic
event check out like there's a million
variables in life but
take away a lot luck like you know do
you know that i do not play the lottery
because i'm scared to win
you're scared to win i do not play the
lottery okay because i'm scared to win
because then everybody will say
that it was the lottery ticket that
enabled me to do the things i'm planning
on doing the next 50 years no
entrepreneur can be successful with
somebody who is not independent
none there's no entrepreneur that's
right no sally if her husband rick
is not independent and can't keep
himself busy and isn't about his life
she can't do what she needs to do
because he's going to be pulling her at
all times and making her feel guilty for
taking that extra business trip for
looking at the phone during dinner and
so you need if you're a true bread
entrepreneur an obsessed entrepreneur
and what i mean by that is i believe i
know your audience i know mine i believe
87 percent of people listening right now
are in it for the money
they're in it for the short term get the
money go on the nice vacations right buy
the nice car if you're part of the 13
that i'm a part of which is you would
die tomorrow if somebody said you
couldn't play
i would much rather make a hundred
thousand dollars a year and i proved
this this is what i did in my from 22 to
34 i made 150 130 167 49 000 a year
building my dad's business for him i
never got upset that i got no equity i
don't have resentment that i left that
business at 34 with nothing i even when
people say to me don't listen to gary
his daddy put him on or give him the
business when i know the true story is i
didn't get anything i just built a
monster business for my dad in my best
years of my youth and then left and
started over
right i mean vaynermedia started with me
getting a client to pay because i had no
money to pay
me and aj or anybody else for the 13 who
are listening
they get it which is like look no
question i think a lot of people like
bull if they don't know me but if you
know me make 14 million dollars a year
right
uh and not be able to play anymore
passive income
make 200 000 a year and get
able to play i'm not even close it's 200
000 play i'll suffocate i'll suffocate
i'm like a fish out of water if i'm not
building a business every moment of my
life since
1987
has been
unbelievably passionately
98 of my human energy against the notion
of
either my family or building the
business that's in my hands at the time
baseball cards liquor store you know my
personal brand vaynermedia the
investments i've made
up selling a book i'm always in project
mode operating i've you know from the
day i started working i've been running
a company in becoming garyvee and all
that stuff there's never been a day
where where garyvee has been my business
every day since may of 1998 i've been
running wine library or vaynermedia all
of them every single day in continuum so
yeah i mean to me
if you're that if you're one of those 13
for all the 13 that are listening if
you're still not married or by the way
if you're married you may want to
consider divorce i'm being really
serious here because you're not doing
yourself a favor and you're not doing
your partner favor if you are not
blindly supported
you will suffocate and die it will not
work it just will not work i think for
some people the come up is easier and
the level up's harder for other people
it's the reverse for me
you know what it's gonna be a fun recall
the same guy who works the room with the
same level of humility and deep passion
to meet people and help them and help
himself if serendipitously he stumps us
into an opportunity uh who loves to
co-sign and watch people shine and like
why not who likes to like
add to that you know uh is it is the
same guy today that was seven years ago
and that's the same with me with wine
techs tops like i'm pretty much
navigating the same exact business
blueprint that got me here
and i'm a more mature version
i'm in the subtleties much better than i
used to be
but at its core
like what you know a lot of times you
hear this saying you know what got you
here is what you need to double down on
and then you hear contradictions like
you gotta change up now that you're the
next level i think people make those
things absolute here's how i see it i'm
i'm tripling down on what got me here
but i'm maturing and evolving around the
edges and changing certain things more
mature more thoughtful not making the
same mistakes um
and uh experi you know experienced gary
should be better than rookie gary unless
it's complete death blow death to me and
my 17 people that i get about like
everything else is super secondary and
let me tell you something if you
actually get into that mindset it gets
real good like everybody like makes
these big deals out of things that just
don't matter it's perspective you know
my selfishness comes from my
selflessness
like it's what makes me feel good i see
it in my mother my mom is the epicenter
to every single person in her life her
sister-in-law her you know cousins aunts
everybody goes to her that's her comfort
zone me too askgaryvee like like this is
my comfort zone like i like this like i
hate when people are like what can i do
for you like i i say nothing i don't
want anything i hate that feeling i went
into my family business because i felt
like i owed it to like pay them back
those are my parents so if that's what i
feel about them what do you think i
think about everybody else
my big thing is this you could have
anything you want first of all because
who am i or who's anybody else do you
comma
just ask yourself why
are you so insecure that you need the
logo of the bmw or the table at a club
or what do you need that for affirmation
of others or do you actually enjoy
actually the taste of alcohol the the
speed of a car yesterday i
forced
somebody to leave the media team and now
work in project management a very junior
employee she's been with us for 18 24
months
i from the tippy top all the way down to
the london office on the micro media
team
demanded as a dictator
to move her from media
to project management on two things one
she was not having a good relationship
with her managers and it was neither of
their faults after i investigated
personally and two
through the series of her communicating
with me i thought that she had
tremendous organizational skills
and i saw her yesterday and she was so
happy i'm a ceo
who happens to also have tens of
millions of followers on social media
does public speaking i'm here for things
like this
i'm stretch incredibly thin
and yet
i was able to execute against that and
this is not me saying it for everybody
who's listening to think i'm good or it
speaks to intent
either
let me save everybody a lot of time on
this incredible mission that this
podcast is on
either a company is about its people
or a company is about money
any company
that is publicly traded
or has a board that has control over the
ceo she or he has to pander to something
outside of their employees
independence
whether in the micro or a massive scale
at least gives you the chance
to be
employee-centric
so how did you communicate that to her
and how did she receive it
well it was in the conversations i was
having to her about her not being happy
and then also double checking and
hearing from her managers that maybe
it's her fault
was data i was collecting and then i
came over the top
with hr and finance and just requested
the
move so i didn't even communicate to her
that i was doing the move
uh it just happened uh she
i when i saw her i'm not sure she knows
how much or how little i had to do with
it and i'm not really in the business of
getting stars on my shirt um but i'm
really happy about it and whether it
works out or not i have no idea but the
moral of the story for everybody one
more time
especially if you're listening right now
and you have the power
you know something i said yesterday to
the london office was everything at
vaynermedia is my fault there's a
thousand things wrong right now
there's eight
to 80 people that are responsible for
that but at the end of the day i hired
and empowered those eight to eighty
if you are lucky enough to have control
and you're listening right now and if
you're listening to this you care about
the things that we care about
please look yourself in the mirror and
realize you're the one that has the
ability to make the change that you
ideologically believe in i don't like
college for the value prop for a big
percentage of people
i think college works for somebody left
a comment yesterday on my instagram that
like garyvee you convinced me to stay in
school
and i was pumped
and and i was like yes this kid is
hearing me i'm not in college i'm
cheerleading for self-awareness
there's no such thing as one thing works
for everyone
this and one of the scariest things
insist in american society one of the
scariest things is parents putting
pressure on kids to go to school to make
the parent feel good and making the kid
take on debt for that when the kid
doesn't feel like they want to do that
and then they come out the other side
and they literally spend the next 15
years trying to reconcile that debt
that's why you have a lot of unhappy
people
and then what that means is then they go
yay i'm going to vote for the person
that's going to wipe out college debt
right because that's your short term
issue just like other people vote to the
republican side on their short-term
issue which then leads to accountability
issues
which leads into people like google
needs to take care of me this is how the
machines are going to win
you understand that right
i don't want the machines to win
i want all of you to think every single
thing is your fault without judging
yourself into depression
which you know everything's your fault
that's a great thing means you're in
control let's go i'm curious now
how do you find the balance between
being a great husband between being a
great father having great health and
building a great empire and what do you
feel like you could improve more in at
this season of life
you know i think i think it you know
back to extremism right like the extreme
which i use
i you know all of it can be better and
all of it is just great i i think you
know here's a good place to go with this
let's really bring value so you can go
back you know four years ago and listen
to like how i think about extremism
going hard and then vacationing hard and
it's all there
i think what this has evolved into is
something a little bit deeper and more
important that i hope really brings
somebody value right now which is stop
beating yourself up and stop judging
yourself
we all go through chapters right like
sometimes you're
super in love
with your partner and like that's all
you can obsess about you know it feels
like that's you've been through that
chapter recently like other other times
you're you know super into your
profession because you got a new
initiative and you got to go it's
another baby sometimes it's an actual
baby and and and by the way for some
people the first two years are actually
super boring because the baby does
nothing and it's okay to not be like
blown away and spending every second on
the flip side if you just can't believe
this little miracle and you need to like
cut work out like i think this comes
down to judgment stop beating yourself
up there is not even a
close framework for what's right
everyone's balance is massively
individual this company is a complete
and utter reflection of the way i was
parented and the circumstances in which
i was parented
100
i think that
this company
is
optimistically practical
so
um
and that's uniquely what i can bring to
the table in this company so this
company is extremely young and coastal
which means it's unbelievably socially
liberal which is incredible because i am
as well but that also leads to
vulnerability
um and so
my practicality in immigrant upbringing
and like merit-based infrastructure
helps us a lot when the most senior
leaders do things that are currently
popular but are unbelievably uh
scary to me of what that could lead to a
month later i mean like
i mean slack at vaynermedia
is like dark reddit
like you know like there's a lot of good
but there's plenty of dark
and like that's just the nature of what
happens especially when what's happening
outside the four walls of vayner media
is happening in our society which is
activating people
in a completely different way than a
decade ago or two decades ago or two
decades from today and so
yes i feel like
i'm very fortunate to be the human that
i am during this time because i think i
have
practical optimism there's a really
interesting thing that an entrepreneur
that she or he needs to be able to
manage a lot of things which is the i'll
use this analogy td this is the easiest
way to put it some people really just
want to juggle three balls and they do
it and nothing falls and they're like
look and i'm like cool that's amazing
i'm gonna juggle 25 plates nine of them
are going to break
right but i but i'm 16 to your three
and because i actually don't care about
judgment
because where people the reason a lot of
people don't do things is look
empathy which is a wine brand that i
launched i come from the wine business
i'm building a machine that's building
brands and if empathy fails that's like
a big l and like like could really like
slow me down if somebody's thoughtfully
looking at me but i'm okay with that l
and i think what you need to do is have
a stomach to be able to have losses have
you had any losses
plenty okay you know when we started
vaynermedia i also launched two other
companies corked and forest
uh a lot of things i invest in incubate
um
here's what here's here's one thing is
part of the game it has to be and and
here's where people need clarity on this
micro failures right right not not
over the last
10 years of my career i've probably lost
millions of dollars every year on a
failure but nothing you're making me
feel real good right now but no but but
the reason making you feel good and i
don't have the details on where you're
going with that is but it didn't put you
out of business it didn't change you
know you didn't have to go and be rocky
five and go back to like you know i
think that when it's all said and done
and we've been talking a lot about
legacy
that when it's all said and done you've
achieved greatness when even though all
along the way
there was a narrative of he's a
or he'll never pull it off or what has
he ever really done
greatness is when you are on that last
day
both the fans
and the non-fans
have to accept
and acknowledge the results
hunger
is a really interesting thing
you know hunger is interesting thing
because when you're hungry when you get
an opportunity you tend to over gorge
when i think back is like real quick on
this it's a really important analogy
that i've never really i've thought
about but i've never said out loud when
you're hungry
and you get to a buffet
you throw up
and so when
when people are hungry for success and
they get in front of me or anybody else
or an opportunity they overeat
the truth i know it's fast and i know
you get it and i think that you're
eating a couple less plates now at your
at-bats and that's why things are
happening man i have definitely
suffocated excuses
better than a lot of people which is
really the biggest reason so many people
are listening right now are not winning
they are surrounded by people that are
willing to accept their excuses on one
very interesting insight it's because
those people don't give
your friends and your family are letting
you get away with your excuses because
they don't care
i weirdly don't know you and i care and
let me tell you how to fix this get your
excuses out of your mouth what's super
interesting is and those people that are
cfos and ceos and ceos
they think that's the magic i always
laugh at them i'm like you're a
commodity right there's millions of you
that's math
that's easy to understand i i always say
if you want to be an anomaly you have to
act like one like people want all these
special things to happen but then
they're acting like everybody else and
that gets into the saturdays on in your
20s like or or just like taking risks or
things of that nature like i totally
agree with you i i think about as you
know that picture where like it looks
like two people kissing or it looks like
a glass of champagne
like i just basically think at this
point in my business life the world sees
the glass of champagne and i see the two
people kissing
like i just can see it like i know
what's coming i think that people need
to try to be self-aware about what makes
them happy and doesn't make them happy
right now social me i view social media
as a as a mirror i think what people are
putting out is an incredible indicator
of what's inside of them
so right now there's a lot of political
anxiety there's a lot of
ideological anxiety and so what we're
seeing is
a lot of judgment
you know i think you know the early days
especially when you and i were on it
like there was a lot of nirvana early
users it was very soft
i think you are seeing
um
a different version of that today
but
that is
you know
getting off of social is no different
than stop watching cnn or fox every
night or reading the journal or times
we consume as animals and i think if one
feels overwhelmed they should stop
consuming
but i don't put social media consumption
in a very different place than
the films and music and and books that
one reads
like
the collective replies of people's angst
is no different than kurt cobain's
singular angst other than it's a
collective versus a singular and so i
think it's great and like when people
like oh like like what are you gonna
think about that i'm like i don't care
about social media i really don't i care
about humans communicating with each
other
i'm fascinated by communication
and i'm fascinated that we now have a
collective ability to communicate a
scale that we've never seen before and i
think right now people are focusing on
the downside of that and i think we're
forgetting the upside of it
there's so much love and greatness going
on every day
i think humans find what they're looking
for
if you're signing into twitter to find a
fight
or to find somebody to fight with or to
see some negativity you're gonna find it
i think if you go to twitter or
instagram to find happiness and
positivity it's there at scale that's
just karma is practical
i love how people think karma is like
this weird thing
doing good for other people is a good
strategy
like i like it's like you know i've been
like trying to really i'm like why does
this thing even exist it's actually the
most common sense thing of all time why
is karma seem weird the [ __ ] is karma
like wait a minute so you're telling me
like if you do lots of good things that
weirdly good things happen to you yeah
that seems like common sense
once in a blue moon i come up with very
tangible advice so i've been talking a
lot about leaving comments in people's
instagram posts but not like follow me
or like just to game it no take the out
you want to grow everyone's like how do
i grow i'm like there's a way it's
called a thank you economy
quietly going like nice and calmly like
if you're a photographer go to nick's
page she's got legit
he takes a photo of some pretty person
boy or girl he's very good at that in
some beautiful setting and like look at
it and then leave a comment that's
meaningful like hey nick you know are
you using this filter or i noticed what
you did with the light there like
something that means something not like
cool or lit you know like you're not
leaving the comment for the sake of
leaking the comment you're taking the
actual hour and a half to like look add
something of value you do that on on
you know
90 different the way i came up with it
was leave your two cents you know in a
comment leaving your two cents go take
nine hashtags
that are relevant to your business and
then go to ten accounts
or or ten hashtags top not it used to be
the top now now it's just random nine
so to pick 10 hashtags the random nine
that's 90. leave two cents
now you've left a dollar eighty for the
day yeah watching the last two three
four five six weeks of people like you
know because it's funny right people are
buying likes and comments people are
like trying to do dumb give away ipads
or yeezys or off whites to get followers
or
you can actually work for an hour add
value know your craft and that like nick
i'm actually looking at it like do you
know what would happen because he
actually knows his craft if he actually
spent three hours a day three hours a
lot of time
but and if he gave a [ __ ] and i don't
think he should or shouldn't right but
if he gave
the fact that if he spent three hours
looking at 20 hashtags in photography
because he's crafted and skilled and
gifted and went to those people's photos
and said that i would never understand
i'd just be like nice thong or like nice
muscles or like cool coconuts like if he
said like oh
i see what you did there off the
reflection horizon
you know
right well that matters because like
people see that you're leaving something
meaningful
right for me
stumbling into the talent the natural
talent
that that very nice bio what i realized
from happy and this might sound very
interesting and it took me a long time
to realize it the reason i had eight
lemonade stands and i did the reason i
had eight lemonade stands as a child
which is absurd and very unique
is
on a stage like this actually five years
ago i'm giving the story i used to give
my bio more and i actually remembered
for the first time why was i doing that
because i was starting to get a little
bit
upset with myself was i lazy and just
wanted my friends to work but what i was
actually doing as a six-year-old kid as
a six-year-old child
i was walking
the 1980s in america was much more safe
so i was walking about in the
neighborhood and i was looking at the
cars driving and trying to figure out
where to put my lemonade stand sign
on which tree
or which post
of a sign
and basically
37 years later right here right now i'm
still doing the same thing i've been
chasing
the attention of human beings
to figure out where they're paying
attention and then
i spend the rest of my time trying to
make a sign
that's going to make them stop and buy
my lemonade would you borrow money would
you borrow money why borrow money now
because you're making an interest on it
money's great right now the problem is
it's the same old game right which is
it's the same thing around the lottery
it's the same thing about all these
things it's
get it's tough for us and i'm sure you
deal with this i i struggle with giving
advice because i need more context
if you're a idiot you shouldn't borrow
money because you're gonna go way worse
you know like like like what's the
difference you're gonna be broke either
way you're an idiot why not borrow the
money
so so look it depends on how you borrow
money here let me let me give you a real
good idiot play
student loans that's the most idiot yeah
yeah because that you can't get out of
that's one of my questions
good college college hate it hate it
right you're entrepreneurs yeah if you
need how much money will you make this
year i will make what are you gonna pay
taxes on what number will you pay taxes
probably 17 yeah okay 17 million right
he's gonna make 17 minutes your best
year it's gonna be your best year
yes so so and he's telling you don't go
to college did you finish
yes but i went to mount ida college yeah
i went to magne state university this is
how you give this how many by the is how
i got to mount out of college i got a
postcard in the mail in march of my
senior year of high school and my mom
finally woke up and realized i had like
she didn't know the process she was an
immigrant and she's like you're going to
college and i'm like no mom i didn't i
like didn't apply for anything she's
like you're going to college i'm like
crap all right and then a postcard came
i filled it out and that's how i went to
mad ida college yeah would you study
there
madden 94.
there's only offense and defense
there's only the force in the dark side
right and i think that um
right now people are
are a lot of people are choosing
to be driven by fear and negativity
without realizing it
and so if you're listening right now my
biggest thing is
start leaning into a little bit more of
optimism and positivity i think where it
over corrects is when it goes into
delusion
and that's when you start creating
entitlement
and that is the tightrope that i've been
talking about thinking about watching
um
and it's i create entitlement a lot of
times because i like positivity and it
took me a little while maybe 20 or 30
years 20 years of operating and managing
and parenting and being like okay
i can see this but i'm not but i'm a
product of not having entitlement what
do you think you talk a lot about you
know delayed gratification there's time
and everyone has a lot of time and
people are wanting things right now
what do you think even with that
mentality i know that you would love to
get results bigger results all the time
with what you're doing you know if you
sell 100 000 books right you would like
to sell 200 000 books right now that's
exactly right right what micro micro
macro yes exactly that's it but what do
you think
you're going to need to do to step into
getting faster results
in the micro and the macro
what would take you to the next level i
think i think what takes everybody to
the next level
is
cutting out dumb
like what if you really look at anything
it's always cutting that's why jack
welch had such a great career he was so
right in like when it was a
revolutionary thought of like cut your
bottom 10 of your staff each year
but it's right i'm like no question
whether in your training in your
business in your friendships do you
understand that if every person who's
listening right now
started to weed off the friend that is
bringing the least value and i mean
they're a bad influence they're
they're they're bad mojo they're bad
like bad i mean they're just negative
they're a negative person so they're
dragging you down they're selfish uh
they have bad habits like a drug
addiction or something and you don't
want to leave them i want to make sure
people people when they hear me say this
oh you
get rid of your friend no
just if you audit your circle of who you
spend time with if you just spent less
time with something that is broken and
you added
one person that was incredibly
valuable your life would be a lot better
that's just real
what is the impact that you want to have
on the world so i would say this is my
current pov because i think it's
actually important that i have a
different answer for this at 50 and 60
because you're going to adjust to the
reality i'll give you a good example if
something terrible happens in my life
and it's disease-based or it's because
some kid was texting while he was
driving and hit my dad those will become
things that i want to leave a legacy
about because that's just how we act as
humans right they become your truths
but no question this will never go away
i
want
to do the following i'm fascinated by
the same thing that attracts
so many of millions of people to people
that are selling
those same people are attracted to me
and what i want to do is suffocate out
all those other people and become the
alpha of that entire world of people
that are
are hoping and are desperate
to look at me and what i want to do is
inspire
two 14 year old girls in kansas city
right now to build a billion dollar
company on having a bunch of employees
hugging each other in the halls
i think that steve jobs came along
became an icon
but the sad part of that narrative was
he did not treat his employees well he
became an icon and the narrative became
he got the most out of people by being a
jerk and that became romanticized and a
lot of people in silicon valley today
run companies where they're mean because
they think that's the right thing to do
because they put steve jobs on a
pedestal i want my pedestal moment i
want to become that big and what i want
to come from that
is that kids that aren't even born today
think that they can build a five billion
dollar company and be a great guy or
great gal i want to build the biggest
building in town
ever
by just building the biggest building in
town while i think most people try to
tear down everybody else's building so i
think positivity and good
is practical advice to building an
empire and i want to be the poster child
of the person that built the biggest
baddest
empire and did it by being a good dude
along the way and not everybody's gonna
be happy about everything i did but if
it's 97 of people talking good behind
your back that's a real legacy and i
want to do it in a pop culture way i'm
going to do it anyway people have done
that before just so you know there's
plenty of people
warren buffett's a really good dude
like there's plenty of people that have
done that
there's a difference i want to do it and
i want to be a rock star right like and
that's where you influence people like
you know like i want to do it but i also
want to be the most popular and so then
that person's like oh i want to be him
so i guess i'll be nice
like i want to literally take people who
have dna that's kind of nice and make
them more nice because they think that's
how i became big so i basically want to
trick
the business world into becoming kinder
when you started trying to care towards
me
as your career evolved over the last
nine years
the first four times that you cared
i
thought
this is the setup for the other thing
the ask or something right because
that's what we as humans think that is
the environment we live in i'm sure
that's what people feel about me
the fact that you look i think here's
here's the thing here's actually let me
say this about you as well there's
this is a good topic
i want to pay forward at all costs i
want to give give give give give get
right jab jab jab right hook like if i
had it my way that book would have been
called jab jab jab jab jab jab jab jab
jab jab jab jab right hook
i think the thing that you have that i
have and this is our kinship and no
question speaks to our success is we're
very willing to give yeah
we're not scared to ask for something in
return
but we are not crippled we don't
overreact to somebody coming through and
we're not crippled when they don't right
i'll give you a great example for
everybody listening when school
greatness came out you know like you
know you emailed you reached out i was
able to buy a bunch of books we did all
the things when when mass came out this
feels like what three months ago yeah
i remember this clearly because i kept
like getting scared that i was [ __ ]
up because you reached out you're like
this coming but i had some [ __ ] going on
just like business stuff you were really
busy too
but i was just really like between
personal life and business and i just
remember like because i remember this
because i was like oh [ __ ] i gotta like
you know it wasn't like notes i'm like
oh i got to reach out to him i got it
and then i like hit you up and i was
like dude where are you like you're like
dude i was in new york four days ago
like
but you know what's interesting to me
that because that's how i play like
sometimes people will come through
sometimes they don't
giving with expectation
is a devastatingly bad idea
that 99 of people do
the amount of money people people are
trying to replicate my model but are
overspending on the tech or the lighting
or the post-production like you know
that's not gonna work
if you're running a motorboat you don't
feel it the same way you fill a cruise
ship it's gonna sink and that's what
people are doing they're overthinking
and then that then led to the next part
which is don't overthink your content
because that wasn't the physical
manifestation it was the mental
manifestation you know you know many
owners and ceos jump in and look at
their instagram account and like i don't
like that picture and it like breaks the
whole machine
like that's you know so like all these
things can you um try and narrow down
what on
what is the number one driver of
engagement in the workplace
the ability to listen
the number one
driver of engagement is the macro and
then the individual employees that make
up the company's ability to actually
listen
i
um man i gosh i i really
cultivating our ability to listen to
employees
um as managers
is
is a very important focus going forward
for you and your your organization it's
the only thing i think about
if you think about the just to create
some uh levels of clarity here for
everybody
the
the the
ability to engage and be engaged and
things that nature completely start with
the seed of being heard
you know somebody being heard
it is completely different than somebody
who feels they're not hurt that's also
what research shows is that true good
that makes me feel good uh
yeah to have to be seen and
to have the um
the opportunity or possibility to
influence um the alcohol situation so
that you're not trapped nothing makes me
more excited than when a junior employee
comes
gives a recommendation
and then seven months later it actually
becomes true and they reach out to me
and they never think it was them
hey gary sarah thompson here you know we
met seven months ago you know just saw
the announcement or just saw this or
this just happened you know i'm sure it
wasn't me and you probably don't
remember that i asked you
but i'm so glad it's happening
and then me on a flight at 1 30 in the
morning dear sarah uh it happened
because you walked into my office
cree where i heard you i thought you
might be right i investigated we did it
it's one of my favorite parts of my job
i'm real passionate about patience
i think the biggest vulnerability to
this room including the coaches
and us old guys is patience i wish
the coaches over here knew how young
they were
watching 30 40 50 year olds completely
confused by the context of time is one
of the most fascinating things i see in
our society like people always come up
to me and like gary when are you gonna
buy the jets and i'm like 25 years and
they get satisfied
like they think
they like want me to have it tomorrow
and i'm like i just don't build wealth
like that i'm just like one brick at a
time i'm not gambling out here or hoping
or dreaming i already [ __ ] up by
passing on uber twice in the angel round
that would have made me my billion so i
missed that shot so the reality is is
that
i'm just building blocks and so
you know whether you deploy this
what i'm talking about right now to like
how you're thinking about cracking the
starting lineup or why you're pissed
you're on special teams but you should
be starting or whatever both excuses you
come up with in your own head the
reality is patience as an overlay is
remarkably important the reason so many
things are easy for me is i don't give
he's using my signature on a thing i
have no idea what he's talking about my
signature is my most important ip
and i don't get because i like him and
fine nate did something when i sell five
bottles 15 cases 40k but like do you
know how many people would freak the
[ __ ] out with that yeah
like so like it just matters the answer
is very individual
you know
there's like most of the things i do
most people don't agree with
most of the things i do most people
don't agree with because i'm unique
in my lack of interest in short-term
money and i'm now starting to debate
even money in itself
i just like my process like one thing i
love about athletes is if if they get to
the right place mentally they're in a
place where they're always ready to get
booed i i genuinely think the reason i'm
super successful is because i got booed
my whole life
i was an immigrant couldn't speak
english got booed
i was a terrible student
a couple miles away from here got booed
right
i was small and not good enough at
sports got booed i got booted at
everything which made me a great
entrepreneur because i'm ready to get
booed i love being booed i love elves
the reason i love the jets and knicks so
much is they have one
i grew up a huge yankees and rangers fan
as soon as they won a title i was out
i'm about to climb i love losses i love
pain
i'm serious i love it
the new view how aware of
are the average business leaders of the
correlation between employee engagement
and profitability
non-existent
because cfos are too literal an excel
sheet
and
90 percent if not 99
are not deploying emotional intelligence
above their financial intelligence
and they are
spreadsheet
basics
and
new kpis yes how do we
how do we clarify this correlation
because it is there research shows is
there you've seen it others have seen it
research oftentimes and reporting
doesn't
penetrate a cliche
cfo
you know they no matter what your you
and i co i comment you know i come and
talk from personal experience somebody
else comes from an academic point of
view on this shows dear
cfo the you know you are wasting 4.9
million dollars a year of people sitting
there and and
crying and not working and if you had
better engagement
you know i i know that to be true in my
bones in my bones i know
that a proper culture
creates a scenario where people have
better output
in the time that they deploy i know that
is an intuitive human
um
but if you're but now let's have some
empathy in the other direction
if you're the cfo of ericsson
and you have to report numbers
and you have to report numbers every 90
days
it gets very hard for you
to make the investment
let's play this out okay so
rick and susan hear us and they deploy
they're bought in they believe in you
and i what happens next well you have to
start putting in money to put into
programs
you have to put in money to put into
human beings that rev up the culture
they
all of a sudden we ask the cfo who's
looking every 90 days
on a whim in their mind because it's not
mathematically quantitative no matter
what our reports show
they have to pour money in to this
for the hope that later it pays
dividends called investment i've heard
people don't invest should i try to
double or triple down on my strengths
within each business as far as
scheduling time doing my thing you
personally yes 100
okay like nothing i believe in more
than the fact that most people lose is
they waste time on trying to fix that's
never fixable
and what i mean by that is
what i mean by that is
i'm not going to be an nfl quarterback
and i'm not going to be not high energy
do you guys understand that if i was 13
less high energy
that i would be two times bigger there's
a lot of people that can't deal with my
energy
do you understand if i didn't curse that
i would have 12 million followers not
six like people don't get it like but
i'm just a buyer of like being who you
are i could be so much bigger
if i toned it down a hair cleaned up a
little language
today
not in 12 years
got it
understand that's how i think about
strengths and weaknesses look i i think
that you know
you know giving is intoxicating once you
get into it but you can't give if you're
not in a place of giving and that
doesn't mean money
that means happiness
and i you know i think i think at you me
others
i'm really really excited i think the
alpha male winner is starting to evolve
i don't think it means being a pushover
like some people get concerned that our
culture is getting too woke on that i
think it means rounded
in that like i i want i want people to
feel comfortable in this in their
selfishness
i love saying i'll do it right now i
want everybody to sign up for
winetext.com if you buy wine
now that's my dad's business but that
that is like my family business so
i want people to promote their thing i
wanted people to buy k-swiss i want them
to buy empathy wines i want them to go
to vaynermedia and vaynerx.com and work
with my companies i want that there's
nothing wrong with that
um and i don't want people to disguise
like you know like you know what happens
you get into this gratitude guilt frame
where when you're saying something you
hedge it with like but it's altruistic
i'm like you can have both you can be
altruistic and give and be awesome and
be selfish and have a boat and a house
and
millions of dollars like it's all good
and by the way you can also do whatever
you want but like but there is no
balance conversation right now it's
almost like you have to be foofy foofy
give away everything or completely rogue
i'm all about me and the reality is
everybody's in between
and i want to be great at both
right like like like
bleeding out of my eyeballs till three
in the morning this whole week every day
and being exhausted but knowing that i'm
one of the three energies there's five
energies alan tish you know michael
rubin the founder of it and me and then
fanatic's company and vayner media's
company they're working right this
second
um
that have helped in five days to raise
ten million dollars that's gonna feed
some kid in mississippi some elderly
woman in westchester like like eat
eat
not to mention
all the happiness that comes when you're
the person that wins
speaking role in leo and you're just a
normal person and for months you and
your friends are just happy every day
talking about it yeah 83 people in your
world
like there's so much good that can be
done
both selfless and selfish so the biggest
thing that i've observed when i've
talked to teams and now speak speaking
to a lot of kids
the
top top for me is
how many people in this room when they
go to class or on campus
are
in a place where their headphones in
focus under given that you have the
leverage right now and the reality is
the kids around you that want to say
what's up are gonna have the leverage in
a decade
i think about this every day
i think about like i always you know
it's funny when i when i talk i always
think about it's funny to have aj here
by having a brother who's 11 years
younger i kind of got a lot of practice
early to like spit wisdom or try to be a
mentor i think about what i would tell
aj if he was
dramatically more athletic and was
sitting in this room and
and i would say like yo bro like
you know this is just the math around it
yet
there's a hundred people on campus right
now who are going to be the biggest ceos
or players in new york city
in seven years and right now they're
dying to take a selfie with you but you
have no time
because you might be caught up that you
have the leverage right now
and that's the biggest mistake
it's the biggest i call it the high
school girl rule right a lot of people
didn't want to talk to certain girls in
high school but six years later they
really want to talk to them but they the
leverage because they were in high
school and i think about that a lot and
i think a lot of you are in that
position right now please don't
underestimate or take for granted
obviously if you're in this room
you know for the far majority of you you
had leverage in high school too from
your athletics
and so you're used to that by now
whether it's one two three four five six
seven years that leverage is everything
in society it's crazy i watch it every
day the whole social media thing
watching the biggest most famous people
in our society only five to seven years
ago
be slow to instagram
because they thought they were fancy and
they were celebrities so they didn't go
on and they made fun of instagram models
and they made fun of instagram comedians
and they made fun of people and now
where that is the currency
and they're not on it just watching the
most famous people in our society
grabbing at straws hitting me up of like
how do i do this
when just five years ago
they had all the leverage
and now we forgot who they were or don't
give it it's fascinating
tell us the story tell us the story
about pulling flowers and reselling them
yes this is who i am this is my dna the
first business i ever had in my life i
would go around the neighborhood i would
pull people's flowers out of their yards
i'd ring their doorbell and sell it back
to them dude that's not you know it's
not super it's not just that's super
epic this is why my dad has such a big
impact on my life when i turned 14 and
got in my dad's business the first thing
he taught me was
that
and it saved my ass the same reason
word is bond
word is bond word is bond and that's it
and it saved me because when you have
this much level of charisma what's that
got to do with pulling the flower i'll
explain okay it it basically elevated
into ethics
okay you know like
it's even the spiel that i look look i'm
not confused that some of the things i'm
spewing here are not exactly aligned
with you or everybody else it's what
feels right to me just like you do what
feels right to you yeah we all say what
we say and so but what my dad did for me
when you have as much salesmanship and
charisma and story capabilities as i do
this is just the truth yeah you can
manipulate i can make anything happen i
can fundamentally make almost any human
do anything
i'm being dead serious make me do
something right now i'll make it i'll
make you do something without you
knowing and then i'll tell you the story
of how it happened okay i like that okay
good so
so wow man you're not gonna like this
you're gonna love it okay and so so
what's interesting about that is that's
dangerous
correct and i don't have bad intent so i
was gonna be okay what my dad did was
speed up what i would have learned by
becoming a wiser man and so at a younger
age i became more straight and arrow and
less foolish
and that helped me so much right if i
didn't think of it as motivational and i
thought of it as strategy
because mindset strategy right like like
being insecure
is a mindset it was put into you for a
million different reasons
figuring out how to get out of that hole
by who you surround with how you think
what you do
if you insecurity is the biggest poison
in our lives
like insecurity scares the [ __ ] out of
me lack of self-esteem is why people do
everything bad
buy dumb to make themselves feel better
do dumb
like take don't put into their body it's
all insecurity
um
i used to remember in high school back
to dating now maybe i'm gonna tie these
stories together
i remember when i realized oh
my friends drink alcohol to get courage
but
but they don't even that drunk they just
use it as an excuse to do that they
wanted to do anyway it's just all
insecurity man
so
um
as far as failing it's interesting i
don't have like a fantastic obvious
failure and that's actually a weakness
because it's very grounded in my deep
deep deep immigrant roots i've never
done anything that has so overextended
myself that if it didn't work that i
would really fail where i've really
failed
is on the things that i haven't done
i've fantastically passed on uber twice
in the angel round and that 25 000 check
would have made me 500 million dollars
i fantastically didn't even reply to air
bed and breakfast email to have
which is what b b stands for uh to
invest in her company i've passed on a
lot of opportunities that have become
fantastic they're the most obvious and
then and then the really biggest
mistakes i've made is
when i didn't come to a conference like
brilliant minds over the last five or
six years and that would have been the
conference when i met someone and she
and i would have done something so it's
much more when you're crippled by
opportunity it's the hidden
things that you've passed on that are
the great mistakes of your career
uh especially when you're like me who's
not ever playing a financial arbitrage
machine game where you're trying to
slide one past the goalie and hope your
timing's right i'm a marathon runner
in a sprinter's costume
and so i i don't put myself in a
position to be that vulnerable um
uh the other thing is in my from from 18
to 29 i worked every single day
all of them
and so
i definitely think like one vacation a
year for a week with my friends from
high school college would have been a
good idea
so i was just so passionate i so wanted
to pay my parents back for being the
greatest parents and bringing me to
america that i was
obsessed with building that family
business and i probably could have had a
little bit more leisure in my 20s which
i regret
not really but yes
you know
not really not because i became
successful honestly because i just loved
it like my you know i
go garage saleing on the weekends
literally go to people's yards and try
to buy things for a dollar that they're
selling that was in their basement and
then think and then repost it on ebay
for eight dollars and in that seven
dollar roi get more excited than landing
an eight million dollar client
so for me business is my hobby it's a
you know and so
that's why i say not really because i
just loved it i loved
you know working the register on a
saturday when i was 25 years old because
i love it when are the moments that you
doubt yourself the most
because i know you're extremely
confident in yourself but are there
moments and what are what are they and
how do you get through it when you have
that doubt in anything you're doing one
of the weird things i do is i don't i'm
in a funny place now where i'm not
putting myself in a place where i doubt
myself and so i always wonder is that
like not challenging myself or is that
like staying in my lane but like i will
tell you like the only thing i think
about being like when you ask me like
what's scary here's
reading in public is scary it's
terrifying because i can't read yeah
even like the last time we did the
askgaryvee book like for the audiobook
it just kind of riffs well you know
what's funny i always do that yeah uh
cause i get bored because that's why i
got f's so i'm like i don't want to read
my own like you know i'm like yes i know
what's in here like
you know that's why people buy the book
in the audiobook because they're like
basically not even the same uh
it was fun actually for me because i'm
like oh i'm a better reader than i've
gotten you know i think i've been forced
to read so much over the last 10 years
since we became a computer-based
email-based text-based world um but uh i
don't like to like i would be if you
were like hey read my notes here right
now to the podcast i'd be like you could
literally ask me to get naked i'm like
all right
but if you said read this right now
verbatim i'm like because i'm i don't
like that uh but man it's then it's
things like a tr like throw me in a pit
of snakes i'm like i don't want that
right like jump off this building that
there's nothing in business that that
makes you doubt yourself and there is
there a situation that you could see
like you've spoken in front of 50 000
people that's not scary
at this point in my career i've been in
the room with everybody
and that means i have not been in a room
with a ton of people but like all the
big leaders
that's right i'm of the cloth yeah uh i
belong you're confident too yeah i'll be
very frank with you i think i'm better i
think when it's all said and done i win
this generation i think elon and zucks
and the uber guys i think a ton of
people make more money i'm convinced now
that nobody will make more money nobody
will make more money and help people
make more money than me in this
generation i will win in that game yeah
in the game of that i like which is
winning personally and willing helping
other people
i don't think i'm gonna be touched i
think i will be the guy i think they
will go back and be like look here were
the people that were entrepreneurs
during a time when entrepreneurship was
cool and here are all the different
things elon invented the crazy
and you know mark zuckerberg created the
greatest and bezos created the best
companies that made the most money and
then gary did the best job of making the
most money and he bought the jets and
that became symbolic but he also created
millions of hundred thousand heirs and
millionaires that's what crush it's
about like and that's why crushing it's
about i think that's really cool i spend
an enormous amount of time
trying to make my audience awesome
out of the selfishness of the legacy not
to get him into a top of the funnel to
buy my book or my sneaker right right i
ask for it but i have zero
vulnerability or expectation talk to me
about how your mom played into that
because
a ton so i know your mom you've credited
her with really helping to build your
self-esteem but you're also a huge
believer in like don't fool yourself
don't tell yourself you're good at
something you're not so how did she
make you feel so good about yourself she
walks
that's a great great that's very you're
doing a good job here thank you sir
that's a very no it's a very good way to
ask it because the truth is
she's strategically used
and real
what i think in hindsight she did was
she over emphasized
things that were subjective or good so
she
really i'll never forget this i opened
the door for a woman in mcdonald's
in edison new jersey
literally like when i was eight just you
know we were both walking with a little
head and i opened it and let her walk
through
if i tell you that my mom basically
treated that event like i won the nobel
peace prize
like three weeks
but but think about how smart that is
like think about how reinforcing that
played out played out so much that one
of the most interesting comments in the
250 blogs that i've done was i got uh an
email from somebody who said hey garyvee
you know this is this comes like hey at
first i thought like uh
you know and then i got into it a little
bit and i was watching this vlog and
then the other day you really you nailed
it home and i'm like you know i'm
reading i'm like i can't wait to see
what i did he's like you went into the
elevator and you let all your employees
go first
and you know it's just so interesting
right these subtle little things it's
important it's so fascinating what
matters to people and i get it like i
actually think that's right but it's so
weaving into me at this point i don't
even i don't recognize that
um
that's what she did well she made she
made big deals out of the things that
were tried and true and then and then
when i got these and f's she punished me
even though she knew i didn't need
school in her heart
she made me know that there was
accountability for things so
i would lose television and video game
and friends privileges for
it would always be for a month she'd
break down somewhere around day 14 13.
my sister would tattle on me when i
would sneak in tv it was a funny it was
a sitcom in itself the three of us um
she uh
she she really made me feel special man
she really did it right she really
really really pounded home my eq
my kindness i've done it with xander too
he went to the playground when he was
two we were at the playground a little
three-year-old kid falls and skids his
knee and he walked over and was like are
you okay and i made that like a two-week
thing right like
empathy right and so and so
she just she just really did a good job
of
making me feel good about the things
that were around my kindness
and
my support of my sister and my
leadership skills and my friends and
taking the you know i took a bullet once
for something my friend did in the
neighborhood and she thought that was a
good thing and just just kind of those
personality traits that i think you know
if we all if all of us everybody
watching wrote down like personality
traits that we admire
anytime i showed any
uh of those actions she drove them home
and i think modern-day parents and most
parents do not do that i think they
focus on dumb like grades uh because
they are insecure and they want to put
the bumper sticker that their kid went
to you know stanford like it's real
when you really think about what's
actually happening um so much of it is
misery loves company or people
reflecting of what's inside of them so
that's my punch line which is like good
behavior is in perpetuity
i do believe in the modern internet to
create awareness for something you want
whether that's to raise money for a
non-profit or to sell glasses
i believe the volume of content is
because then you're able to
contextualize it to your audience is
absolutely the leverage of the current
state of consumer consumption
um
one's capability financially energy wise
creatively
you know
but it's no different than saying run
really fast
if you can really really fast faster
than anybody you can win an olympic gold
medal and then make 25 million dollars a
year in sponsorship if that's what you
choose or live in a cave and say i want
a gold medal
i'm i'm speaking to what i genuinely
believe is the right strategy
you know how one interprets that you
know
is really up to them when me and my dad
started having too much friction because
i was getting the credit and became the
man and he was so when did that happen
that happened probably seven eight years
into me running the business okay where
it was like gary not sasha right and
then that because my my dad's an alpha
and his pride became this country with
nothing 100 his pocket and built
something
but then i took it to such an extreme
level that it was friction and i was
like this man i'm not gonna not have a
relationship with my dad
my brother was graduating college i was
like let's start something new
so the truth is it wasn't that i woke up
and i was like wines whack or i want to
do something else it was that like i
just wanted to like have a real
relationship with my dad and i was
starting to like get really worried and
so did that start like an addictive
process in which you just kept having to
like move on to bigger and bigger things
i don't know if it's that i think uh
from my standpoint
you know the answer i gave to you i eat
my own dog food like straight up like i
deploy patience like i didn't think
twice that at 34 i didn't have a whole
lot of money i built my dad's business
for him i was leaving with nothing
really nothing nothing i didn't i don't
own anything from wine library it's i
love when people leave comments like oh
this guy his you know his dad gave him
four million dollar store i'm like no no
i built my dad's business for him to a
totally different level he gave me life
and gave me the opportunity to build his
store for him but at 34 years old i'm
worth dick
zero so what do you do from there
i get some guy to pay us eighty thousand
dollars to be a vaynermedia client i get
mike boyd to work for free and sleep on
the floor we grinded and seven years
later we have 150 million dollar
business
and uh i just worked to me
it's something that i'm pushing more
clarity around which is
i want you
to be happy and accountable
of course well the beauty of
entrepreneurship is without there is
it's inherently accountability otherwise
it fails
i do want people to be happy and i
actually think accountability
leads to happiness
when you think the government's in
charge
the the media is in charge facebook's in
charge this boss is in charge when you
believe somebody else is in charge of
your life you
immediately start the process of
unhappiness
accountability is the framework of
happiness
it doesn't mean bad things aren't
happening it's not delusion to the macro
injustices of the world it's called
accountability you know my failures are
funny because i'm an immigrant so i've
always got net i never do that's like
going to put me totally out of business
i always got a nest egg i'm always on
like third and a half bait like i'm
never doing something that's like over
the edge and if this it's like
you know my biggest mistakes have been
the things i haven't done i referenced
it real quick if you go read my first
book in 2008 crush it 2008
i thank my family and one random person
travis kalkanik who went on to start
uber who used to when me and aj started
vaynermedia used to fly around like in
vegas and just hang out with us because
he had no job he was in between
starts uber i'm investing like crazy on
everything he asked me to invest in uber
twice and i said no
because i just bought an apartment i was
a little less liquid
i thought it was a side project for him
i also thought uber was like a rich
man's game like it was originally like a
limo on your phone so i was like you
know how big is that going to be
and i passed twice we got in a little
bit later
you know so we did all right but
but i mean i left i mean if i wrote my
normal thousand twenty five thousand
dollar check i probably left in the
ballpark of 300 to 800 million on the
table
so that's an l
and on some real like
i don't even feel it because what i've
started to really learn about myself in
the last year or so
is i'm about the process not the
trophies
i'm just about the process i love my
game
i love my game so much
i want to win i'd like to have that w
but uh
money's funny right like anybody who
doesn't have it thinks it's the key to
happiness and they're super confused and
then they say well easy for you to say
you you haven't i was like yo i didn't
have it for a long ass time i lived in
the villas and springfield avenue in
springfield
an apartment until i was 28 buying
nothing making 40 50 thousand a year
working
90 hours a week in a liquor store so
i've tasted both
so
i made a lot of mistakes i pass on all
sorts of
i just don't know what the mistakes are
because i say no so much because i'm so
busy what if that one meeting was with
you know
a lot of mistakes i believe one of the
great ways to
mix things up
is
what you listen to and who you surround
yourself with
um
i would i'm
unbelievably passionate about people
finding more optimistic practical
friends
and i and i think optimism gets
can get can slide into delusion which is
why i say optimistical practical
you know uh it's funny as you were
talking about minimalism like i didn't
it it's so interesting that you're the
first person to ever say it to me that i
can recall and it feels very real to me
like i don't have outside things
kind of driving me
and that's what leads me to a lot of
happiness and so
i i would say auditing your circle
like if somebody wants to meet a minute
for life live a meaningful life leave
just get happier i think the people that
you spend your time with is a big one
the amount of people listening right now
who've got a mother who's super
pessimistic and cynical
but they love their mother and they
don't realize that
cutting down their time from seven hours
a week of engagement with their mother
to two and adding
like going out of their way to seeing
the person that's always smiling in the
office
and trying to spark up a friendship and
become friends with that person and
cutting up that seven hours a week from
mom to two to mom
maybe 30 minutes with that person and
maybe reallocating the other hours to
themselves or other things
is a massive deal
it's a massive deal a word that has been
really running through my head quite a
bit over the last couple years is
entitlement
mainly because i have exploded on
instagram and i get 10 000
direct messages a week from kids
who are
wealthy affluent being totally taken
care of and they hate their parents
for creating entitlement and they don't
know how to get out of it but they're
making a lot of excuses that's a
different story
but what i realized is that same thing
that a 19 year old whose parents have
paid for everything and she or he is
realizing wait a minute i'm a zoo animal
and i don't know how to live in the wild
i believe there's a level of entitlement
that is rampant amongst the fortune 500
or biggest companies in the world of
thinking
that they're entitled to the business
they make audit dashes
and points of view on their competitive
landscape they say
silly things like like
make razzes and jokes about
emerging competitors who eventually
become their biggest issues and i've
been thinking quite a bit about that and
i think it all leads to actually a very
interesting place which is ultimately
both high net worth parents and
executives of very big companies
unfortunately are not consumer centric
unfortunately play within their b2b
confines
score on different metrics than the
actual end user that they're supposed to
be deploying for and so
my
luck
and that's what i'll call it of dna of
only ever being consumer-centric
has led to the honor of sitting here and
talking to you and having people pay
attention and all the nice things that
have happened to me and it's fun
because there's nothing more
entrepreneurial or rogue or disruptive
than actually caring about nothing in
the middle but the end consumer
pandering to nothing not awards not the
press not the media not the b2b
environments not the conferences not the
people that are fancy
just the end consumer
and building leverage there which
ultimately gives you leverage with all
the things that i just mentioned that
are in the middle everybody has that
back the difference
yeah the difference between lebron and
beyonce in the story i said in the first
segment is there are gatekeepers
that decide if you could become lebron
and beyonce you have to go in aau
basketball yeah you have to go to
college the nba scouts have to know who
you are you are not some random dude in
iowa who's just great at basketball and
then you can go to the nba
entrepreneurship is somebody watching
right now who's never made the leap who
has the talent they don't need harvard
business school they don't need you and
i they need nothing that's right if
you're good enough the market will
accept you and that fact that we can all
have an at-bat
to do that is special and you don't have
that and that's why american idol worked
people got at bats it wasn't clive davis
and that's what entrepreneurship you're
saying there's fewer filters than the
entrepreneurs and whether they
you've got to do it this way or if i'm
saying it you got to do it that way or
cuban says it's that way or ferris says
it's that whatever it is
as long as they keep hearing a lot of
different things and make their own
recipe
that's what i'm hoping to do you may
love
talking about basketball you might just
be boring
so you've got to be self-aware about it
but my big thing is you may be boring
but it makes you so happy like my big
thing is people don't like their jobs or
lives and then they go and consume
things to escape and i'm trying to get
them to create
to get happy
you may never become stephen a smith but
if you start a podcast about the
pelicans
even if it gets a little juice maybe
some free tickets to a game now you're
pumped you like the pelicans
it's a lot better than watching an
entire aaron hernandez netflix
documentary
i also think that
all of these things that we're talking
about can be scaled right so
my career is going along nicely and then
and i'm winning on email marketing 90
open rates and i'm winning on google
adwords the day comes out i'm buying
every wine term that's working for my
dad and then
comes along youtube
and i see this platform and i say to
myself there's something here
and
you can't run ads on it on the top at
the time
so
when i decided to do a show
and i never thought of myself this gift
of you know i thought of myself the gift
of gab but more like a good salesman or
you know a class clown that the teacher
kind of liked you know and so i
didn't realize what i was going to be
able to do in that format but i started
a very big show that garnered a lot of
attention
and it really really worked and it
really got going and it really taught me
oh my god i don't have to spend
marketing money this attention is
trickling down organically
to my dad's business
there's something here and then twitter
came out and i start using it to promote
wine library tv
and i'm like oh my god
this friendster myspace thing is about
to become much bigger this so sure it
wasn't called social media yet
it was called web 2.0 twitter was known
as a web 2.0 app and
i started using it and google buys
youtube for 1.7 billion dollars and i
say to myself
oh my god i was right about this i was
right about google adwords i was right
about email i'm bet i'm not a wine
retailer i understand what people are
going to do
i need to become an investor in what i
think people are going to do in 2007 i
invested in facebook twitter and tumblr
and that obviously changed my life my
brother was graduating from college i
was starting to make videos about
business that were catching people's
attention and
in 2009 i decided to start vaynermedia
to do marketing for the biggest brands
in the world so i could learn big
business because i understood silicon
valley i understood small business
entrepreneurship but i didn't understand
executive fortune 500 land and i didn't
understand why they were doing so many
silly things in a world where i thought
netflix facebook
amazon were going to be the next big
thing and they turned out to be way
bigger than i even kind of predicted
even though i was predicting the tippy
top and so
that's been my career i've written five
new york times best-selling books around
marketing and um
and
consumer behavior and psychology
but what does all this hyperbole around
me mean it means that
i believe that every person who's
watching this right now
is me
in 2009. here's what i mean by that i
had a level of success
i was good
i was enjoying myself i was building a
big company for my parents i was excited
to think about what i was going to do
for myself next
but the scale of the internet by using
the tools
completely changed my life
and i believe that
what the internet does is exposes things
so i don't think the internet changed me
i don't think it made me nicer and
stronger at my craft i think it made
more people aware that i was nice and
strong in my craft
and so
i think for everybody who's watching
right now i don't think they realize
that if they started producing content
on linkedin about what they know
not what you think people want not to
get followers
but to put out content of what you know
storytell my grandpappy taught me when i
was 10.
this i now did this for my sales person
today that's the video
you don't have to be an expert i'm not
an expert i'm a person that has
hypotheses and opinions and because a
lot of them became true after 15 years
and i've put the actual business wins on
the board now people look at me in a
different way
but i don't
even you know even the flattering
introduction and our talk beforehand
you know she makes me feel so good but i
don't think that makes me special
i think it's just a nice feeling to be
admired
you know
and and i think when you layer humility
and curiosity
around being good at a tool great things
happen let me give you an example
when books came out yeah i'm being
serious now when books came out
clearly and i have no knowledge of this
but this is very easy to understand
clearly
there were individuals
who became more aggressive at reading
them
and amassed knowledge and my intuition
is
the ones that were able to be practical
and operating were able to do something
with that knowledge and succeed
when tractors
and innovation
hit farming
the people that didn't demonize it and
many did
many said that's not real farming
because they were fearful that it was
going to take away jobs from their
people which was a nice thing but they
were trying to fight technology which is
always the wrong answer let there be no
confusion if you hear or
feel anything from this keynote and q a
today please let it be this
if you are fighting against technology
you will lose
it is the history of mankind
we are absolutely at an inflection point
where there's people like me and
different things happening where we're
starting to have different conversations
like nothing freedom is what everybody's
chasing but they're confused about what
it actually looks like it's not how much
you make it's how much you spend
there's a lot of people that could be
way more free
if they didn't overextend themselves on
what they're buying
what's keeping up with the joneses yeah
it is the poison of our society to scale
i do believe you need culture you know
at a thousand people we have offices in
singapore and london and chattanooga
tennessee like you've gotta you've gotta
really have culture
i think the fact that you're even
thinking about it
already means you have a shot at it it
means you're going to throw money at it
and you're going to have an hr
department that cares about the
employees not as a disguise for the
finance team to fire people
it's just intent
like just even hearing how much you know
talking seeing your vibes in the crew
this is just intent
the reason i always win is because i
have intent my employees first my
customer second me third
that's a very easy way to win in
business
i think we all know that's not how most
people do it
and if you're sitting here right now and
saying me i'm gonna start this business
to buy a boat
to customers because they're the people
that can give me money three employee
you're gonna build a very small business
if you're self-aware you don't
try to do things you can't do
you focus on things you do like
you don't try to be something you're not
if you have self-esteem you're not
scared to put it out the content the
video the picture of the audio
because you're not worried if
sallypants49 thinks you're ugly you're
not worried that rick thompson from a
competitive company says you're stupid
you're just not worried you're not
worried that you have bags under your
eyes or you're overweight or you're
losing your hair you're just not worried
you're you're focused on your
self-esteem you're focused on yourself
you're focused on your self-awareness
which puts you in a position to succeed
and so all of you one of the worst not
worst one of the challenging times in my
career was around 2012 when people all
wanted to be like me and i'm a very very
over-the-top
high-energy personality who's very very
comfortable on video and that is just
not going to be the case for everybody
and i tell everybody and it took me a
while to get to this good answer which i
think has helped people listen my
friends if you're watching this right
now and be like okay i see what gary's
setting up he's going to ask me to start
producing a lot more content that's the
answer by the way
well i don't want to do video well i'm
like good news sarah you don't have to
do video
you might for example i'm a terrible
writer if i was a great writer i'd be
writing a lot more
because writing on linkedin crushes as a
matter of fact my team loves when i i
write all the copy on my instagram posts
right all of them everyone every post in
my life
and they get pumped when i get motivated
and like write a real good one because
we know the post does better copy is the
most underrated thing in social media
today it drives so much of the success
of the picture in the video so
by the way you might be an audio you
might be a talker but you're insecure
about your visual of how you look or the
camera makes you freeze but you're great
with talking so good there's now
clubhouse an incredible app you can go
and be a thought leader in there's just
recording audio and posting that on your
linkedin linkedin for this group knowing
who's in the room
is equivalent to what facebook was
in 2012
that will lead to incredible financial
and emotional
success to those in here that heed the
call that i'm yelling today period end
of story i could not be more passionate
about everybody here getting very
serious and then what you put out
is up to you you know my recommendation
is that it brings value to people
whether it's entertaining whether it's
informational but i also believe that
stories stories are
easier for people this is something that
i'm going to start talking a lot about a
lot more about
i think stories just stories like life
lessons grandma told me and then if
you're good at and i've already talked
brought this up i'm going to bring it up
again because i'm trying to help
everybody here give you some training
wheels
if you say hi i'm karen i'm a sales lead
at this company i this is for my team
but honestly this is for the broader
world because i all you sales leaders i
know how it is
you know when i was nine my grandmother
took me to
a girl scouts event and sarah johnson
did this and my grandma i did this and
grandma told me to do that and then i
did this and me and sarah johnson were
best friends in high school and that's
ironic because i had a big tiff between
carl and carla recently on my team and i
did this like my grandma did that and
now they just closed the biggest account
together that story
that should come very natural and by the
way you don't need to call out carl and
carla right because that's active you're
in the world right now you'll be two
people on my team just think about how
easy that is
for what everyone's struggling with
which is well what do i post
what do i post is grounded in lack of
self-esteem and lack of strategy
period
and so
i'm here today to
build your self-esteem
and not in a delusional way i'm just
trying to encourage you to realize how
real this is because the
content creators that build awareness
and audiences will have the leverage in
business whether it's a small narrow
world and by the way this is a small
narrow sector most of the business
people on this call in this thing that's
great actually
the reality is that's great because then
you run a couple dollars in ads on
linkedin against targets of companies
that are in your sector and you're
getting exactly who you want i actually
like
when groups are narrow because you can
get so much more specific
so anyway i'm just very excited to be
here i want to encourage
everyone to realize the opportunity
again if you can get to the place where
you have social you need to write sing
and dance on instagram use hashtags
right you got the book you can read it
you can go sell it for four bucks i
don't give what you do but you need to
go out and you have to make content at
scale because if you can sing
you need exposure
so if you can sing
well then
my question is
this is not just you know like i think
people get confused by making it if you
want to write sing and dance
you also have to figure out how how
that's balanced with how you're going to
live
right so there's a big difference
between being beyonce and being somebody
who makes 50 000 a year singing both are
interesting that's your talent so first
of all you got to figure out how good
you are because people are delirious out
here
people think they're going to league
people think they're going to their next
meek you know people think that the next
beyonce like people are delirious out
here
meanwhile some people are it so to me
here's the funniest part there's no more
debating take your phone
point at your fit self and do it and
then figure out if people like it and
when people say they don't like it you
gotta make more of it you need two three
four years of rejection before you give
up
years people post one post on instagram
of them freestyling people hit on them
and they give up we've literally built
society backwards
like when you first get out of the
school machine which maps zero to real
life
you're supposed to go play real life to
have a chance to figure out what you do
so
i mean where do you start you start with
what are you consuming and paying
attention to when you have leisure time
do you play video games do you listen to
music do you like to go out and eat
weird food do you like what do you like
that's where you start so what do you
like huh man like what are you about um
good let's start with comic books
do you want to create conor books do you
want to sell comic books do you want to
buy comic books and flip them do you
want to work at comic-con all of those
things would be a good place for you to
start cold email and dm 850 different
people that are players in the comic
book world and one of them might reply
to you and that starts your career
like you could literally work for fun co
tomorrow you could literally work for
marvel tomorrow you could
you just have to write 137 compelling
emails and dms and linkedin things
what's up with that
yeah bro you can literally do that
who's who's 43 and older
we couldn't do that ahmed
that's not how it worked
when we were coming up the game you
didn't just like say
like you know that actually ironically
once in a while i come across an og
who's like actually i did do that i
wrote 800 letters
it took two months for me to get a
response instead of two hours
but yeah man i mean like you know in the
comic world there's the movie aspect
there's the actual skill of it make like
if you go like if you like the drawing
of it you could
look let me tell you one thing about
winners
a lot of winners didn't get there by
accident so when you write a winner an
email your favorite illustrator at dc
comics hey sarah i will bring you coffee
get your laundry
grind and bleed just to intern or work
at minimum wage just to see how you do
it everyone wants to be an entrepreneur
well maybe not everybody but a lot of
people do but
very few people actually pull the
trigger and even fewer succeed what are
the barriers there
talent
that's disheartening that means you're
just like you're born you can either
play in the nba or you can't no what you
that's a very good point i think it's
the following my brother aj is a better
basketball player than me because he's
put in more work on his left hand in his
jumper so he deserves it he's not in the
nba
you can be an entrepreneur the problem
is we've lost sight of being an
entrepreneur who makes 137 000 a year
doing what she or he loves is an amazing
life but right now everybody thinks
they're going to be mark zuckerberg so
we've become audacious and ludicrous and
delusional in our entrepreneurial uh
ambitions
and so i think we need a level of
self-awareness i think people are trying
to be entrepreneurs at a level we've
never seen before because the cost of
entry of saying that you're an
entrepreneur in your instagram account
is very easy
it's also cool right now i'm actually
quite scared about that because i don't
want to be the face of that because i
think 95 of people are going to fail
especially when the economy fails let me
say something straight to camera
if you're not a successful entrepreneur
right now in the easiest time to be a
successful entrepreneur because there's
so much money in the system and the
internet is at scale you suck
all right that's some tough love right
there it's the truth this is the easiest
time in the history of life to be a
successful entrepreneur and if you're
not and you're struggling
then you're not an entrepreneur listen
i'd love to be playing for the jets and
the knicks or be
opening the grammys it's fun sounds rad
just not capable doesn't mean i can't
sing better doesn't mean i can't be a
better football player backyard in
central park
you got to put in the work and you have
to be self-aware of your upside the
other thing is we have too many students
who now think that entrepreneurship is
cool if you weren't selling lemonade and
baseball cards or pogs or burning cds
and flipping them in school like if you
don't have sales dna or operational dna
or it wasn't fun to play
store when you were five
you didn't gravitate it towards it
naturally you're gravitating towards it
now because it's cool right and i take
it you did all those things all those
things right and and so did so many of
the people that are successful as
entrepreneurs right yeah yeah the same
as singers went to choir the same as
actors signed up for the thespian club
freshman year right like it matters the
work matters the talent matters final
question what's your definition of
greatness
uh you know i've never really thought of
that you know it's funny couple things
ran through my i'll just go with what
ran through my head first thing that
came to mind is that
a lot of people know who you are because
you've impacted them in a positive way
um
the second thing that came through my
mind was interesting was
when you say somebody's name you feel
something
like you know that you know like when
you get nervous like some version of
like excitement and butterflies
um i think it's you know i'm fascinated
by the word great because i think it's
one of those words that has absolutely
been like
you know like i think about sports
casting it's funny everybody's nostalgic
about their youth and you always become
the old man or old woman
like
the amount the weight great gets thrown
around
you know i'd love to get your
perspective on this because you've
anchored into this so heavily but like
yeah those are those you know those are
the two things that come to mind like
that mix between nervousness and
excitement uh in your stomach or like to
me it's like when you hear a name like
it's funny martin luther king's birthday
was the other day right i went to martin
luther king
middle school like like i don't think we
can wrap our head around the people that
have changed the world because that's a
level of selflessness like i'm pumped
because i'm going to be 50 selfish
selfless and i think i'm going to be
legendary for it there's people that are
100 selfless
um
i think for entrepreneurship you have to
be 50 of each um but it's wild to me
that i am going to be far more
successful and great
because of the dm that i'm going to send
to a kid tonight
than for the 97 things i'm going to be
right about in business over the next
century
and will make me successful
um
doing the right thing is always the
right thing
there's something in that statement with
greatness i think to be great you have
to be an enigma
you have to be like against the status
quo you have to be willing to say
work life balance in its current state
like i did earlier in the
you know segment so
yeah just just different like and
invoking a reaction a human reaction
must occur otherwise you're not great
how do you actually account for how much
you have actually done or how do you
account you know how productive you have
been as an entrepreneur today for
example i could write one article and i
could be very productive i could write
three
three articles but i'm not productive so
how do you actually account of you know
how much work i have done as an
entrepreneur
you it sounds like you're doing what we
all do which is it sounds like you're
being your own judge and jury right
so i think you just need to love
yourself more right
i'm being serious it's a very
interesting insight like when you were
asking the question
i think every day i'm phenomenal
i'm being dead serious
because i'm trying as hard as i can
i have very good intent
i'm really trying
and if today was a less productive day
because i was tired or a meeting didn't
go well or who knows why i'm just not
capable of beating myself up today
i look at it over the course of time
i mean
i you know you get to be the judge and
the jury what i was definitely when i
transitioned from wine to let's say
entrepreneurship in my content it was
2007 89 and we were going through a
global economic crisis and as you can
imagine as an immigrant who answered
your question of what my regret is
i don't i think it's very difficult to
give advice that says become more
talented
be born with more talent
very not practical
so where i found myself was going to
another place that felt very practical
to me and as you can imagine it's all i
ever saw for the first 35 years of my
life which was work ethic
was a controllable part of the game
that if you did that
if you're out working your competition
practicing after practice all the things
we know about sports and music and
theater and acting and all these things
that that was an incredible advantage
and in a time and place where people
were getting laid off
and things of that nature it hit the
right tone it was natural to me and the
timing was right the lack of patience
bro
i mean it's crazy to me that literally
patience and insecurity
is 90 of the unlock for everybody
listening right now
their mom on them their whole life and
said they're gonna be a loser so they
believe it because that's what parenting
is
uh and they just wanna have a
you know maserati now
and they'll do whatever it takes to do
it and so they'll take they did
something like how many kids are doing
something smart like doing a good retail
arbitrage on amazon right now and making
a hundred thousand dollars by buying on
alibaba and selling in amazon took a
year and a half three years to get good
at it but now we're taking every profit
and buying some rando cryptocurrency
because they're playing the lotto
that's just re this is what's going on
in our society like we have to have
these conversations they're saying big
gains fast like let me just like there's
a kid who spent three years being
disciplined and getting good at retail
arbitrage it's a real skill to have an
eye for like what to buy in china how to
set up on amazon properly how to run ad
like it's a skill yeah
they did it for three years meticulously
they made thirteen thousand and forty
seven now they finally are making three
hundred thousand and they could be on
their way to ten million yet they've
chosen to kind of stop
jump on the short-term bandwagon of
buying some weird cryptocurrency hoping
it's the next bitcoin or ethereum i'm
just seeing that every day and i'm just
like it's it's being predicated on short
term yeah you hear one story zucks did
it
instagram sold in 550 days for now um
that's why everybody started an app
company to follow the leader
completely predicated on short term i
went the other way while everybody was
blowing up i decided to build an agency
boring ass
yes business in the prime of my career
when everything was going for me in
silicon valley
i'm proud of that the holy grail of life
professionally is to love what you're
doing and be good at it
you know there's a lot of people who
love what they do and they're okay at it
there's a lot of people that crush at
something but hate it you know
and the only way you'll know that is if
you taste more
i always i always smile when i'm on this
kick because i think about oysters a lot
so like i'm really into them and like
like i've gotten pretty knowledgeable
about them like west coast east coast
like that kind of
and it's just so funny how many people
have decided they don't like oysters
without ever having them
and that's how i think about careers
you think you're fin ops but you're
really strategy you think your strategy
but you're really account
you think you're project management
but you're really thin ops
and i think about that every day when
something is working and clearly things
are working for you right now what i've
noticed for a lot of people over the
last decade is when something's working
from a monetization standpoint
you start losing your balance of jabbing
and right hooking
i think in a world where you're
monetizing audience coming into things
they pay for
that you have to find and that's why
you're doing this and i think the more
things like this
where you can provide upfront value with
no clear path to transaction finding
that balance is a challenge for
everybody right and most of all when
it's going well so i don't have a good
read on how much free content yeah we do
about eighty percent eighty percent yeah
so there you go so then i would say
eighty two percent yeah or anything
because because i mean that great
because because what i do know is that
people have a much longer life cycle
when they disproportionately bring value
right when you were guilty yeah yeah
yeah and that's the word
guilting people into buying a thousand
dollar program or 20 book because you've
given them more value you've given them
a thousand and one dollars up front you
win so you talked about the volume and
uh
5000 pieces a day yes but you also
talked about the importance of being uh
relevant yes and having meaningful
content how do you ensure that you stay
relevant to your followers and uh
the question is
in a ambition of thousands of pieces of
content a day
how do i also
nail home relevance which is a big part
of it so ironically this volume
framework
inevitably creates relevance
what will happen it's kind of like a
workout plan if i'm able to get my
partner's friends people i care about
clients my own stuff into a framework of
volume inevitably let's just say
somebody was in here and said approved
and everyone's like okay now we do it
inevitably tomorrow's board meeting
is well what are we gonna say
and what you realize is and this is
devastating like one of the things
that's been really fascinating and we
work with very large companies
uh is once you see it
you can't unsee it
and and the level of
visceral negative
energy i have towards the modern day
marketing world
watching some of my clients starting the
process of going there it's real fun for
me because literally a week earlier
they're having this subjective
completely non-practical meeting and
then a month later after the first month
of this work
they can't even stay in the room for 10
minutes because it seems so silly it's
like many things in life once you see
something sometimes you can't unsee it
so
the entire model is built on relevance
all of a sudden you are making a piece
of content to female cios
in russia
because you're making five thousand
pieces of content
like you're not going to make vanilla
anymore
you're in the business of selling
vanilla
you are everything is so over
corporatized and everything's trying to
reach everybody
it be even when the seed of the idea was
a good idea by the time it sees the day
of life it's vanilla
when you've made the commitment to
producing volume
everything is relevant because you start
becoming educated on how deeply
powerful these platforms are and if i
want to reach a cto
that went to mit
and i want to use mit colors
in the creative because i know that
makes her or him more likely to click it
i mean this is real stuff now
all of a sudden
five thousand you can't imagine how
quickly through a detailed conversation
around this five thousand seems way too
little
everything like just think about the two
examples i gave you and how your mind's
running with the fact that this is
actually in perpetuity
every school
every neighborhood every geographic
every job title every organization like
that's just the framework of seven or
eight cohort beginnings that is an x and
y which allows you to go forever you
could be making content that starts with
hey are you 28 years old and the person
sees it is yeah i am
you know like you can't imagine how
infinite
this actually plays out and so you know
it was fun to hear you asked a question
because i was smiling inside i'm like
it's it's once you make the commitment
to that framework the only thing you can
do is relevance
and by the way relevance is the only
thing that sells not potential reach
which is the currency of big companies
grps and impressions and the cost of
those impressions
potential reach
not actual reach
it's being reported as you reach those
people you don't believe that
you don't believe that article reached
29 million people
potential reach
versus actualized relevant consumption
that is the delta i also think that when
we start demonizing work ethic we get
into i think we
are the byproduct of the last 10 years
being
so
fruitful
you know a lot of the people that push
against me are venture-backed company
founders
who
were able to raise
25 million dollars over four years based
on their idea by never running a
profitable company
so everybody and not that they're wrong
i just think everybody has different
perspectives
so
i think we need to get into a healthier
you know minimalism i'm sure i don't
know i assume there's some sort of
counter debate to it and oh yeah yeah
like yeah the minimalism is dead and
it's it's just the whole thing i mean
from the same perspective of hustle it's
like well it's not a cult these are just
some ideas
i think it's important and i think you
know for example i think i both love
work ethic and minimalism and i think
they're you know i already know that i'm
a kind of enigma and have like some
pretty contradictions within me
so i'm hoping that because of that and
that's just the luck of the draw of dna
um
and given the platform that i've earned
and been afforded um maybe i can create
some better conversations because i
think i think it'd be a really good time
for all of us in any sector about any
debate red versus white wine let alone
minimalism anti-minimalism hustle
anti-it's a really good time to get back
to a cordial state
of
debate
i also know it's contextual
like how can't you tell somebody who's
not afforded any opportunities that work
ethic isn't going to help them there's
no no thing you can pull up that speaks
to me saying money is happiness i wasn't
raised in that environment i know it's
not true how do people shift their
mindset even in a horrible time
for most people
when they can't even do it during a
great time
easy
i'm my stuff
does better during bad times they have
to right you and i hung out during the
crush at book signing that's when you
drove me crush it hit a nerve because
people needed it 2009 right right and
that's when hustle
was good and then hustle during good
times becomes manipulated into burnout
but i promise you right now i don't use
hustle anymore because i understand how
the word got
mutated into leading to anxiety and so i
don't want that so i i changed it even
in question i talk about nine to five
making 40 000 a year being happy but
but i promise you hard work is about to
be put on a pedestal again roadblocks
are self-imposed based on judgment from
other people
think about you know what this is a
perfect analogy think about how many
times you guys get banged up on plays
during games that so many people would
take themselves out and not play at all
or
that you know when you get banged like
football's crazy
you guys are getting banged up on every
play
and think about the tolerance you guys
know you guys all know everything you
know the kid in this room who gets
chipped up a little bit and is out
and you know the person that's on this
team right now they'll break the back
and play
but for normal people like me i'm like
every play would get me out that's how i
was as an entrepreneur
that i think people think of roblox
do you know what it feels like to be 26
years old
have people that you went to high school
with come to your liquor store look you
dead in the face as they pulled up in
their bmw and say
oh you work for your dad
and then you ring them up on their case
of champagne that they're going to use
for their party and you bring it out to
their car and put it in their trunk and
they look you in the face with pity i
lived that life
and the way i took that scene was
i'll see you in 10 years
i was a dnf student
i uh
i sucked at school
like i got like i actually was so bad at
school that i had my
my admin my my assistant reach out to my
high school and get a copy of my report
card so i could put on instagram the
other day because people are confused
what success looks like or how you get
there doesn't mean that you should look
at me and not do school it means that
you need to look at yourself and figure
out who you are
what are you good at what do you like
how are you going to get to the place
that you want to get to
and so for me
i got four a's in high school my entire
career all in gym
right like i got a d in yearbook
you know and so to me there's just a
thousand paths out there and so
for me i'm curious about one by one one
by one for the 30 people in this room
where's their mindset where are they at
who are they listening to
what are they judging their self-worth
and their ambition based on
how are they counting the points because
when you're a youngster
you're looking at all sorts of different
things you're being affected by all
sorts of different voices
and for me the only thing that worked
even though i was getting d's and f's
and all my friends parents told me i was
a loser even all my teachers told me i
wasn't going to be anything even though
i didn't have stuff even though i was
i just was in my own head i knew exactly
who i was but the thing that i was
willing to do was i was willing to work
and the thing that my parents taught me
was not to dwell
not to cry about it i didn't have [ __ ]
when i when i rolled up on my mom when i
was nine when nintendo
was popping because
when it first broke i was like mom i
need nintendo she's like good go get it
and so
i shoveled snow and
i ripped people's flowers out of their
yard and sold it back to them
i think again what i'm really trying to
establish in this talk this afternoon
this morning is
i don't think people have quantified the
opportunity
i struggle regardless of circumstance
when with people dwelling or complaining
in a world where the internet is free
has no idea who you are could care less
it's right there and it becomes a game
of skill not necessarily finances to
actually win
it's interesting to me it's interesting
to me that you can be in the retail
business
overnight
by setting up a shopify account which
costs nothing
when that same action to sell something
30 years ago meant that you had to sign
a lease
and build out a store and rely on the
local traffic that walked by it scares
me and excites me that the biggest music
company in the world spotify was built
in sweden
uh by a kid and on and on and on and
you've heard every story
but more importantly for every
ridiculous story we've seen of instagram
or facebook or uber spotify
there are
hundreds of thousands of stories
of people with wins that are micro
versions i actually think the most
unhealthy thing in entrepreneurship and
opportunity is the big stories that
everybody thinks they have to build a
billion dollar company
i think we do not talk enough about the
practical 150 000 a year 300 000 a year
seven hundred thousand dollar a year
business
that you genuinely love what you do
and you can live your life
being happy and financially sound and
what the cost of entry to be able to do
that is in today's environment which
once again let me say very slow
between putting out a media company if
you decide to put that on a wordpress or
a squarespace a retail company
on
the back of a shopify you could start a
radio show that is global
on the back of just uploading something
you record on your memos
on your phone and upload onto spotify
and apple and soundcloud my friends
distribution is free
i know it's a nerdy thing
like it's not like some big profound
statement but let me say it nice and
slow
distribution is free it used to cost a
fortune
now what you put inside of it is the
variable of your success not your
financial capabilities to create the
distribution
you have like i wish we could zoom in i
literally have goose bumps on my neck
right now
no but really i really do it's like a
very i i
i will live my last breath
trying to
get people to understand this is
remarkable
this is this is a game of perspective
are you educated or capable of seeing it
from the lens that i'm speaking about
today which is the barrier to reach the
end person whether you're a financial
advisor and trying to get to a client
whether you sell bow ties whether you
want to be how about the fact if you
want to be a professional football
player and now there's all these
websites where you can upload your film
because the scout didn't come to your
tiny tiny town and now you actually can
be discovered
like
everything has changed
my question and my dream every time i
speak is can i get one person in this
room
to get their piece i think one of the
most important words for me to
communicate in this talk today by far
is patience
i promise you no matter what you're
doing in this room and especially as i
look around this room
first of all everyone's uncomfortably
attractive and number two
and number two but more importantly this
is quite a young audience and i think
the reality is
the thing that i spend most of my time
on is trying to get people to understand
that patience
is a very important variable of success
and more importantly
that i believe the far majority of
people in this room do not have a great
relationship with time
i am fascinated by people in this room
who are stressed
at the ages of 18 and 22 and 25 and 29
like the running out of time how many
people by show of hands are under 30
years old
[Laughter]
so for me
as you can imagine
when i see all those hands go up you can
put your hand down
yeah you're good okay good
when i see all those hands go up and i
know in my mind with the way that modern
medicine and technology is going that
the far majority of this room is going
to live for another 80 years
it really gets me
excited slash concerned when people want
their business to be huge next year
the quicker you want it
the more vulnerable you are
the quicker you want it
the more vulnerable you are
and what has been very fascinating for
me is even though on
youtube and instagram and maybe some of
the places you guys see me maybe my
energy is high
maybe my style of communication is fast
but my business actions are extremely
slow
so i highly recommend you get your head
into a place where you just go on the
offense
straight offense
because you have the options
you have the options and so
i think it's the greatest time to be
alive the internet is still new
there's still so much to take
you could absolutely grab it
it could be yours
it's just about going into a different
place in your mind
and getting real quiet
thing that got me through
is everything got quiet
everything became charlie brown
all those teachers all those parents all
those people telling me i couldn't or i
wasn't
or i was losing
i just drowned them out and so
that would be my recommendation
drown out the noise
and get real focused on the opportunity
the way i deal with chaos and the way
that i would deal in chaos if i was a
upper middle leader in this team right
now is realizing what's the alternative
you're in control the reason chaos is
easy for me is i know i'm in control
when a tornado or a hurricane or a virus
or
sales drop breaks out i'm in control
coronavirus china sales are down we're
in control we get to sit in a room and
say what are we gonna do okay i love
chaos like if mike tyson's running at me
and i'm a boxer that chaos this is why
holyfield beat him you're in
control yeah it's not fun or scary or
whatever but you can duck i'm most calm
when there's the most chaos because i go
into a place in my mind of like what's
the worst that can happen
why don't they die
oh no
then business who gives a crap put it in
perspective put it in perspective stop
being scared you want to win
in 2021 be nicer
you want to win in 2021
have more compassion you want to lead in
2021 lead with this not with what your
head thinks your wallet is going to
benefit from and i know that i'm
sounding fluffy and
but let there be no confusion i'm an
assassin when it comes to business
you may be hearing fluffy things but let
me get real close to the camera here my
friends
i'm trying to win the whole thing i'm
trying to be the greatest entrepreneur
of all time i believe that kindness
compassion empathy sympathy first for
your employees then for your customers
and then
you can think about yourself
is not mother teresa stuff it's not
gandhi now some mandela stuff i believe
that it is
sheerly and obviously the foundation of
successful business in today's
transparent
universe
your meanness
that you think is motivating
it can't be hidden the way it used to be
and so i want people to lead with
optimism kindness and all these kind of
soft skills because i think they're the
emerging superpowers of business
and i think a lot of you should really
be paying attention to it i love that
everybody's so into math and big data
and quant and have not deployed the
level of gratitude around the math of
400 trillion to one which is the odds of
being a human being
there's nothing you'll ever accomplish
that's more remarkable than that you
have a chance to accomplish something
if if we can lean into gratitude
a lot of good can happen
i don't know i'm just super grateful and
it is an enormous
there is no red bull there is no soda or
coffee that comes anywhere close to
gratitude
people think i'm drugged
i haven't even smoked a cigarette in my
life
because my mom got nancy reagan you know
and so
so
i just came to realize oh this insanity
is predicated on gratitude when you're
so grateful for the at-bat
you're happy
but people dwell about dumb
yeah the small stuff is so small and
people like mad when they get the wrong
milk
like seriously i go to starbucks you
know i travel a lot you go to starbucks
and like i asked for almond milk i'm
like this bought a seven dollar coffee
like it's crazy
doesn't matter with people
we need to start some sort of cultural
rule that anybody who's mean to somebody
that works at starbucks should get
punched in the throat
like it should become a meme
like it's the collective responsibility
of somebody to punch that person in the
face my greek grandmother and
grandmother
came from the old country and really
almost every time they drank tea or when
the men were drinking vodka you'd always
kind of do this thing where you spoke to
good health everything was to good
health to good health to good health
i think it brainwashed me in the
greatest way of all time i
for me 2020
is
a year that has incredible underlying
pain for a lot of people who feel that
they were robbed of years with people
they love
i am one of the lucky people that did
not have that happen and so thus
after that
you know vayner speakers and and vayner
productions took massive hits lost
millions of dollars doesn't register
because that's business that's almost
like not real life like money is not
real life real life is very basic
do the 12 15 20 people i love did they
live in 2020
and yes amazing best year ever
and and you know i also am a good
operator but i will say this if i owned
15 restaurants
it would have been and we were mandated
to close
now from my perspective because i always
believe in innovation i believe my door
dash and uber eats and direct to
consumer would have been stood up
already and i probably would have grown
and and and i think it forced a lot of
restaurants to finally do the right
things
uh and so it's just a really interesting
time if you're a capable operator and
you have life in a simplistic mindset
you're going to be happy way more often
i worked for my dad's liquor store when
i was from 22 to 34 years old i built my
dad's liquor store to a 60 million
dollar business and at 34 years old i
left and had nothing
it was my dad's business i would inherit
it one day but i hope my dad lives
forever and i'll be 90 right so
like i did what i thought was right
different circumstance but i did what i
thought it was right i was an immigrant
kid my parents took me from russia to
america i wanted to pay them back i
worked my face off gave up all my 20s
right super easy to be humble with her
when you're humble
you know so
you know when i hear you asking that
question without knowing every one of
your details
i think you got to do what you have to
do to get to the next step to give
yourself more options
got it
so like if you're good at it and it
works and it can get you to that next
spot that gives you options at 30 how
old are you
mazel you're 15. if that can get you to
a place of 27 that gives you options
you'll be a kid at 27. at 15 you think
27 is dead old i get it
i remember
but i'm telling you your face it's young
kid you're a young kid
how many people here would love to be
27.
get to that next spot
i get it listen
let me tell you one thing that you will
not hear often the person that knows how
to eat the most amount of
usually eats the most amount of caviar
got it
you need to eat
get to the next spot
not directly
but you understand
if it's good like that and i can get you
to the next spot that's perfect
regardless of what it is
whatever gets you to the next spot is
exactly move forward
it's good man i'm glad you if you have
something like that bruin that excites
me that's real easy for me to see how it
can go for you you just got to be
patient
that's where you got to stay disciplined
and save that money and not buy
all the stuff that's getting fed to you
that you need
it's hard to get to the next spot when
you spend 700 bucks to buy a supreme bag
we do not have the proper context around
entrepreneurship we until we start
understanding the level of talent
involved in it we will always undermine
how difficult it is because we think
it's a process and that doesn't mean
again this is why underlining that we
have to contextualize how awesome it is
we have to start putting on a pedestal
starting a direct to consumer
you know
jam business on shopify where you make
183 000 a year because you love making
jam because you and your grandma made it
and like that being a massive success
because you're happy
and you can live your lifestyle and you
live under the means of 183 000 a year
we have to put that on a pedestal that
is when entrepreneurship can hit its
golden era you've got two choices
every day of your life you're either
optimistic or you're pessimistic you're
either seeing what's good or you're
seeing what's bad my whole life
even when i was like in a very different
place i would always just say seven
billion people now it's seven seven
seven point seven billion people where
do i rank
for all that i got for all the
negativity where do i rank am i better
than the person that's terminally ill
that has a lot of money that's going to
die in a month yep
am i better than somebody who's living
in a cage in parts of the world that we
don't even want to look at yeah
and so
to me this is a mindset game if you try
to figure out how to bring value to
somebody
and you
persevere like i really do think there's
a play here and honestly
to be very frank i think josh building
really meaningful business
i'm not in a mindset of investing now
i'd rather buy sports cards than invest
in companies but
um
even though it wasn't like a perfect
execution for me of like i'm getting
this value then let me have him on the
podcast
it was it was so important for me to
have a actual human manifestation of the
thing that i want all of you to do out
there which is like look
if you want to be a rapper produ a
producer for rap like go
ask 47 000 times metro boomin
you know sunny digital like murder be
like just
ask like
ask now
if you know how to ask with grace it's
going to work better if you know how to
reverse engineer the person of what they
care about at this moment like if
somebody has a new album coming out and
they're your favorite rapper
uh young nudie
has an album out today if not if nudie's
your guy
like you could have made 25 pieces of
content on your if you're that person
and sent it dm to him to help him post
on his social channels because everybody
needs more content and then that might
have been the reason you got the job so
there's a cadence to it my deep capacity
to be empathetic and grateful which
transforms in what most people see is
somebody who markets
but in the way i navigate my life and
the way that i market to the end
consumer
my
unbelievable opportunity to speak in
front of this crowd today is predicated
on listening i talk you listen to my
podcast i interrupt every single person
that is on my show
because i've already heard what they
said and i just want to move it along
and we don't edit
it seems mean it seems audacious it's
deeply based on listening we have to
start the process of listening to the
youth they're telling us the answers you
just care what your neighbor thinks
about your kid you just care about what
your mother thinks about your kid you
just care about what your sister thinks
about your kid you need to start
listening to your kid on social i watch
so many kids that i'm looking at
watching them progress
have a terrible game throw four picks
delete
delete it
hit me up on dm i'm gonna garyvee i'm
gonna detox off insta i know we've been
talking but like off this this game last
week i'm done i'm coming back in october
and i always think about that
and we all have to figure out our
relationship with technology
but here's how i take it from my purview
i think people get too high when they
get cheered
i think the reason people struggle when
people get on them in comments
is because they're taking other people's
opinions way too serious
the best way to be able to help take
care of and deal with people on you
is not getting too high when they're
giving you accolades
when i watch videos like that when
people give right now i'm on that place
where i get so much love
i i don't hear them
i really don't
i understand i appreciate it feels
humbling as
you know but i don't hear him
i still think i suck i'm grinding i'm in
the process it's early
which is why when people [ __ ] on me and
they do
a lot because when you're out there like
that that's just how it is
i can't hear them either and so one
thing
one thing i would consider is actually
using social media's negativity
and judgment
as an ability to actually absorb it
create a framework where you can
actually accept
both pros and cons at scale
instead of running away from it every
time i see somebody shutting down and
deleting i get nervous
because i don't see it as a detox
for 99 of the people i talk to
i see it running away from judgment
and judgment is the only thing i promise
you that you'll have for the rest of
your life
and that you have had i believe in work
ethic like nobody's business i believe
that work ethic is an enormous variable
of success you
i and
controllable
which is powerful
however my you know through the years
what i've not done as good of a job
though i've sprinkled it though i've
done unique pieces of content about it
though my second book was called the
thank you economy though in my first
book crush it i speak about this the
reason
this is a very easy answer for me is the
way you sustain it
is loving it
it doesn't become
being a workaholic when you're doing
your hobby
the reason i started telling people that
any the reason i you know when people
hear anybody can do it they're like yeah
gary this is the secret you it's i'm
like no no
take a step back we now live in an
internet world where the cost of entry
is zero
and every one of us who's listening
right now has a passion whether that's
fishing fashion hair coloring drinking
wine sport
i believe that anybody can start the
process of creating content
around something they're passionate
about which will always do better than
something you're not passionate about
and that over time that may lead to
something that can
pay you 30 40 80 000
euros or dollars a year or eventually
millions if you're ultimately talented
if you're sitting here right now and
you're real real passionate about
something that doesn't have to do with
the four walls we're in right now you
need to lean into that
because that's the thing the internet's
doing
the amount of people that can make a
real living
around having a podcast or a vlog or
flipping they love
versus getting a job they hate
and they can make as much or around the
same much around having a
podcast around fortnite versus going and
working in finance because they intern
this summer in wall street and they
think that's where the money is that
i know nobody here believes but i've
been saying it for a decade and i'm
watching it every day and it's real to
me i'm trying to get so much done in the
18 hours 19 hours that i'm awake that to
me every second matters and if i can
hack it like i'm gonna do it and so yeah
i'm a big fan of not spending time on
that doesn't matter or the stuff i'm not
good at
but i'll spend three hours reading every
comment because i'm good at looking at
it and synthesizing it and then
understanding what is going on right and
so i think people think there's some
smart way to do it the smart way to do
it everybody is to figure out what the
[ __ ] you're good at quadruple down on
that
and punt everything else
my ambition
10 years ago stays true today i want to
buy
some of the most nostalgic brands that
have ever existed when the next economy
collapses so when this economy finally
collapses i want to go buy
kitkats bubblicious k-swiss you know
ralph lauren i want to buy brands and
then i want to be the ceo of it and what
i knew then was i understood small
businesses i understood silicon valley i
didn't understand fortune 500 businesses
but i wasn't going to go get a job so i
decided to start the agency because at
that point i realized marketing was my
superpower hanging out with all those
silicon valley titans
why was i invited to the dinner why were
they listening to me it's because they
were great at tech
but i really understood one of the
biggest reasons forget about the current
way people view mark zuckerberg and
facebook
mark zuckerberg's deep understanding of
human psyche was the number one reason
we connected i think i'm an extremely
good marketer because i think this
entire thing that we're at right now is
an internal b2b ecosystem and the only
thing i pay attention to is the end
consumer
i know so little about what's going on
here
this is
this is literally the first three years
i was here i only did this event i
didn't know anything else you guys
remember i don't i s harriet just joined
us to run comms from bbdo she's
incredible i'm still asking her on the
way here she's like we were
fine finalist what's it called
shortlist she's like we were shortlisted
for a bunch of stuff today i'm like i
don't even know i literally thought it
was finalists like i still adam
yesterday we won a silver thing and i
was like what does that mean like i
still am so
deeply unaware of what's happening here
not out of audacity not out of
disrespect i actually love coming here
the vibe i love hanging with you guys i
love this
it's just that everything i think about
is the consumer
it's the only thing that matters and and
that's why i believe that
you know i'm humbled by some you know
the most interesting or one of the one
of them we're doing some of the most
interesting things
because we just see it different
we just see it different and the way we
see it is practical so i mean
the far majority of what you've already
worked on you would have never consumed
that's the truth and i think that's
that's my
aspiration to come to things like this
actually have a conversation about what
the hell is going on right like
creativity is amazingly fun
i think that we have to be very
thoughtful that somebody's paying us to
make something happen
you know i think there's a lot of
audacity that seeps into this craft
where it becomes about ideology and and
selfish behavior i watch creatives and
strategists make decisions
all the time based on what they want to
blow up a building they want to meet
john legend they want this joke to see
the world it has nothing to do with what
the client needs and definitely nothing
to do with does the end customer care
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action for the next week
when you watch a video and just get
motivated the science says you have a 35
chance of actually following through on
your goals that's not good enough no not
for you believe nation we got to do
something but when you write it down and
you create a specific plan of action for
the next week that number jumps to 91
chance of you following through and when
you commit to somebody else like leaving
a comment on this video it jumps to 95
you need to follow through on your goals
so what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your specific plan
of action for the next week put it down
the comments below so i can celebrate
you
grew up in an environment where my dad
worked every minute to try to make it in
the new world and he eventually owned a
liquor store in new jersey i was dragged
into that when i was 14. and really from
day one
um i started doing two things that are
interesting to me i started doing a lot
of ui ux which in in the way i would say
that was i started moving my dad's store
around i used to stand behind the
register and it wasn't that busy right
like you know you know where i could
watch almost every customer walk in and
where would they go and what would they
buy an intuitive as 14 i would
understand like why do we send them that
way where we sell stuff that's not as
expensive as over here like really in
you know a lot of this stuff the last
five years i've recalled even lemonade
when i was six years old
instead of standing behind my own
lemonade stands i got my friends to do
it because i would literally walk up and
down the streets of new jersey
watching cars drive by to try to figure
out what tree or what post to put a sign
on
so i've been truly intuitively chasing
attention my whole life as a matter of
fact it's gonna bubble up in a minute
one of the biggest reasons i push
against television advertising and think
it's grossly overpriced and overrated is
not because i don't believe in the craft
or a 30-second video it's that i don't
believe people are consuming them
you know like that i think that needs to
matter you could literally make the
greatest thing of all time it's kind of
like the tree in the forest like
you're gonna spend nine months making
something that nobody sees seems like a
waste of time if you want even more gary
vaynerchuk motivation check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there you know i hate
things like nice guys finish last where
it's just not true
nice guys might be losing at halftime
but they win the game
nice guys always win